Leute, ich bin wieder da, ich muss gerade die Streamkategorie umstellen, fällt mir auf,
weil ich bin immer noch in Just Chatting, im Prinzip keinen interessiert, aber ich denke
mal, falls das Leute gucken, die sonst nicht zugucken, dann finden sie das in der, oh
wie heißt diese Programmierkategorie, ich glaube die ist Game Development and Programming
oder sowas. Software und Spieleentwicklung. Warum ist mein Browser auf Deutsch? Kein Wunder,
dass ich da nichts finde. Software und Spieleentwicklung. Und KS. Meinig.
Na ja gut, erstmal warten wir, bis Twitch gecheckt hat, dass der Stream online ist.
So. Ja, ihr werdet's nicht glauben, was ich
schon alles gemacht habe hier am Label Champ, wo ihr nicht dabei wart. Der ist richtig,
das ist richtig Professional Bildbearbeitung mittlerweile. Na ja, Bildbearbeitung ist ein
bisschen sehr hochgegriffen jetzt vielleicht. Professional, anordende, anordend Ding, keine
Ahnung, wie man sowas nennt. Layout, Layout Programm. Illustrator kann einpacken oder
was, was nimmt man dann aktuell? Was nehmen denn die ganzen Pros für Layouts? Die nehmen
bestimmt nicht den Label Champ, aber was nimmt man da heute? Illustrator oder, also
wie gesagt, ich bin zu lubig für alles. Ich benutze entweder Affinity Designer oder Affinity
Photo. Johi, Dankeschön. 28 Monate Paint. Ja, da gibt's tatsächlich genug, die Paint
verwenden. Weil ich nicht so genau weiß, warum man Paint verwendet. Ich mein okay, ich verstehe,
warum man Paint verwendet, aber warum man Paint 3D verwendet, verstehe ich nicht. Ach,
InDesign ist es. Illustrator ist das Vector Ding, gell? Stimmt, so war das. Das ist gut,
dass da auch Pros was mitmachen, ja. Aber für mich ist das deutlich, also als Noob
ist es deutlich besser da durchzublicken als Photoshop oder sonstige Sachen. Vor allem
das Gute ist, du drag und drops Zeugs rein, machst ein bisschen Anpassungen, schon sieht
ein YouTube Thumbnail ganz gut aus. Irgendwas anderem kriege ich das nie hin. Bei Affinity
kann ich quasi einmal Gatchirole über die Tastatur machen und dann sieht das Thumbnail
halbwegs brauchbar aus. So Leute. Affinity ist günstig, ja. Haltet euch fest. Seid ihr
bereit für die aktuelle Version des Labelchams? Was geht bei deinen Tabs, wieso? Die bewegen
sich nicht, da geht gar nichts ab. Die sehen aus wie immer. Falls du allerdings darauf
anspielen solltest, dass das so viele Tabs sind, das ist normal. Das muss so sein. Ich
mein, warum habe ich 16 Gigabyte, Moment, habe ich 16 und 32 Gigabyte RAM? Wait a minute.
Warum habe ich 32 Gigabyte RAM, wenn ich die nicht auslasse? Tabgruppen, ja habe ich ausprobiert,
hat mir nicht gefallen. Hatte ich sogar letztens noch installiert. So muss das sein. Einfach
komplett voll bis oben hin. Heck wait. Was hast du eine Idee, was man mit einem alten
32 Bit, ein x86 Tablet, was? Aus Windows 3.11 kann man doch, du findest schon Linux, was
da drauf läuft. Aber nachdem es ein x86 Tablet ist, garantiert läuft da Linux drauf. Allerdings
wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt, sondern nicht gut, um es dann als Tablet zu bedienen. Weißt
du was? Ganz ehrlich, weißt du was die beste Idee ist? Schmeiß weg. Wenn du irgendwas
spezielles vorhast, irgendwie Heimautomatisierungs-Dashboard oder sowas, hol dir irgendwas Aktuelles. Ich
glaube, außer du willst rumbasteln. Wenn du rumbasteln willst, dann ist natürlich verständlich.
Okay Leute, ich zeige euch mal was. Seid ihr bereit für den Label-Champ in aktueller Version?
Ihr werdet begeistert sein, ich sage es euch. Soll ich rüber switchen? Postchamp? Soll
ich rüber switchen auf die VM? Okay, ich switche. Ich trinke was vorher. Erstmal taktisch
die Spannung auf vorn. Okay, Achtung. So, ich hab was gedrungen. Das geringverdienter
Mindset für alle, die keine 16 oder 32 Gigabyte RAM haben. Hey, warum hast du keine 32 oder
16 Gigabyte RAM? Das einzig erschwingliche aktuell an Hardware ist RAM. Das ist das
einzige, was du dir aktuell kaufen kannst. Keine Zeile weiter als vorher. Du wirst gucken.
Bam. Sieht schon mal optisch deutlich besser aus. Wir haben jetzt eine Anzeige. Also erstmal
scale das mit dem Fenster. Jetzt ordentlich. So. Dann kann man rein- und rauszoomen und
ihr seht, er zoomt zum Mauszeiger hin. Seht ihr das? Er zoomt zum Mauszeiger hin. Also
du kannst jetzt richtig wie in einer normalen Bildbearbeitung zoomen. Kannst aber auch das
Fenster resize und er macht es immer gleich groß, so wie es sein soll. Du hast die Anzeige,
wie groß das aktuell ausgewählte Label ist. Du hast einen Selektor, wo du auswählen
kannst, was du für Labels haben willst. Hochformat oder Querformat. Ja. So, es geht noch weiter.
Ich muss mal kurz überlegen. Ach, das beste Feature habe ich euch ja noch gar nicht gezeigt.
Also die übliche Geschichte ist weiterhin drin. Man kann hier Dings einfügen und so.
Man kann Text einfügen und so was. Funktionierende Sache hier für Text-Edit haben wir auch schon.
So, und ihr habt es schon gesehen. Guckt mal Leute. Habt ihr gesehen, was ich etwas eingebaut
habe? Schaut mal. Seht ihr das? Wir haben massive Ausrichtungslinien, wie auch immer
die Dinger heißen. Guck, du kannst jetzt was hier andocken. Du kannst jetzt was label
an der Ecke. Und es snappt auch. Ich zeige euch mal. Guckt mal, es snappt. Ihr seht ja
meinen Mauszeiger. Und jetzt, zack, snappt das automatisch neben dran. Mehr Features
als Battlefield. Guckt jetzt, snappt das. Und du hast Hilfslinien zum Ausrichten. Also
wenn du jetzt irgendwie einen Text haben, wenn du einen Text haben willst in der Mitte,
kannst du so machen. Guck, kannst den Text oben, oben, bisschen oben, so, oben Mitte ausrichten.
Und dann kannst du sagen, ich möchte aber in der Mitte des Textes und der Mitte von
dem Icon mein Icon haben. Und schon hast du es perfekt aligned auf dem Label. Dein Text
und dein Icon. Und du kannst jetzt nachher auch hingehen und sagen, ja ich will eigentlich
Roboto Mono draus machen. Da siehst du, aha, es ist nicht mehr richtig ausgerichtet. So.
Und zack, wieder richtig ausgerichtet. Ist das nicht nice? Aber man kann doppelt klicken
für Auswahl. Man kann Farbdinger anpassen. Schwarz-Weiß nur, weil der Label Drucker
ist nur schwarz-weiß. Guck, wieder nicht richtig ausgerichtet. Bam, zack, richtig ausgerichtet.
Ja, das ist gar nicht so einfach gewesen, kann ich sagen. Zum Glück konnte ich ganz
viel von der Webseite copy-pasten bei denen. Wird der Inhalt jetzt auch mitskaliert? Ja,
selbstverständlich. Guck mal. Der Inhalt wird mitskaliert. Und wir zoomen auf den Mauszeiger.
Guck mal, wir zoomen jetzt immer auf den Mauszeiger. Der Inhalt wird mitskaliert, ja.
Das funktioniert auch. High Fat, ja. Es ist äußerst agil gesprintet hier. So, ansonsten,
was hat sich sonst noch geändert? Eigentlich so auf den ersten Blick nicht viel. Das ist
noch das, wo ihr das letzte Mal auch gesehen habt. Jaja, auf dem Handy geht das auch. Guck
mal, das ist sogar halbwegs responsive. Guck mal, wenn du es auf dem Handy-Modus hast, dann
geht das Menü unten. Wenn du es auf dem Desktop-Modus hast, dann geht das Menü links, weil du links
mehr Platz hast. Progge. Ab vorhin ein Stream auf YouTube gesehen war von, oh nein, die Typen.
Drucken kann es noch nicht. Nee, das ist aber auch tatsächlich, das Drucken ist das einfachste
an der ganzen Sache, weil wir haben schon geguckt, wie man druckt. Das ist tatsächlich relativ
simpel. Ich muss im Endeffekt das Ganze einfach nur als PNG exportieren, was nicht schwierig
ist. Born Zurück-Funktion. Ganz ehrlich, keine Ahnung, ob man das braucht. Weil ich
meine, was machst du auf so einem Label? Ach so, ja Moment. Ich habe euch ja eine weitere
Sache noch gar nicht gezeigt. Guck mal, du kannst Bilder copypasten. Oh, das scheint
mir noch ein bisschen verbackt zu sein. Die Größe stimmt nicht. Aber die Bilder sind
dann, macht er schon schwarz-weiß für Label-Drucker. Ach so, du kannst übrigens auch flippen und
sowas. Und wisst ihr, was noch viel besser ist? Wisst ihr, was noch viel nicer ist?
Anstatt Bilder zu copypasten. Man kann jetzt Elemente copypasten. Guck mal. So, machen
wir mal den Text hier. Keck W. Indie-Flower-Font. Und ich will den Text jetzt doppelt haben.
Ctrl-C. Achtung. Ctrl-V. Bam. Man hat es jetzt nicht richtig gesehen, weil. Ctrl-C, ich
muss es jetzt wegschieben. Ctrl-V. Ctrl-V. Ctrl-V, Alter. Kann jetzt copypasten. Guckt
euch das mal an. Massive copypaste. Und das funktioniert nicht nur, das funktioniert
nicht nur mit Text. Das funktioniert auch mit Icons. Copy-Paste. Paste. Paste. Paste.
Das funktioniert sogar mit QR-Codes. Copy-Paste. Stellt euch das mal vor. So, ich glaube,
das war jetzt alles, was ich eingebaut habe. Das fügt an derselben Stelle hinzu. Ja,
Text fügt er dort hinzu, wo du copypastet hast. Ich glaube, Bilder sind insofern verpackt.
Die fügt er immer an 00 oder so hinzu. Aber es gibt Schlimmeres. Bessere Updates als
Battlefield. Ja, hoffe ich ja mal auch. Das Edit-Menü übrigens noch nicht fertig. Edit-Menü
geht aktuell nur sinnvoll für Text. Das muss noch etwas Sinnvolles machen für andere Elemente
als Text. Ja, und guck mal, sogar die Anzeige vom Label scale mit. Wir können uns heute
überlegen, was wir heute machen, weil im Prinzip so langsam, aber sicher, würde ich sagen,
kann man das wirklich verwenden? Gibt es ein Scoreboard? Naja, du kannst theoretisch
ohne Probleme ein Scoreboard machen. Du kannst dann 100 zu 5, nächster Player, 55 zu 40.
Hast du ein Scoreboard. Kannst du machen, das funktioniert. So, ich überlege gerade,
sonst noch irgendwas Neues an der Optik, was ich euch zeigen kann. Ich glaube nicht. Der
Material Design-Icon-Browser ist immer noch da. Man könnte zum Beispiel machen, wenn
man reinklickt noch, dass der Browser zugeht. Das wäre vielleicht gar nicht so blöd. Wenn
ich Text deselekte, geht es schon automatisch zu. Aber hier noch nicht. Tabellen erstellen
wären auch nicht so leicht, das weiß ich nicht. Ist bei Google das CSS kaputt?
Ist bei Google irgendwie das CSS kaputt? Die Seite ist so hell. Guck mal, das sieht
normal aus und dann update das. Ja, ne, Presets, ich mache, dass man das speichern kann, das
ist Presets genug. Kann man Tabellen machen? Ich glaube nicht so einfach.
Also auf Deutsch klingt die Frage ja noch bescheuert. Wie mache ich aus einem Kreis
eine Tabelle? Sind die jetzt komplett durch oder was? Was machen die hier? Okay, keine
Ahnung. Ich muss es nicht verstehen. So, so sieht es jetzt aus. So, ich überlege gerade,
ob es irgendwas gibt, was ich euch noch zeigen muss. Aber ich glaube, als Tisch, Table, nicht
Tabelle. Ach so, der Table, nicht Tabelle, Table. Da habe ich mich verguckt. So, machen
wir das erste Mal zu. Vielleicht müssen wir erst mal updaten, da bin ich mir gar nicht
sicher. Zeigt mal her, Pacman, Update, UpdateChamp. Nö, nichts zu tun. Wirklich nicht. JetBrains
Toolbox, K-Q-Aid, wer braucht das denn? Gucken wir mal, ob es neue Sachen hiervon gibt. So
und jetzt können wir uns überlegen, was wir machen. Nachdem ja so die Basic Funktion eigentlich
ganz gut abgedeckt sind. Was treibst du, Willes? Ich baue den Label Editor weiter. Das sieht
gar nicht so schlecht aus, muss ich sagen mittlerweile. Das hat was. Ich meine, es ist
noch ziemlich bescheuert, hier oben was hinzumachen, weil ausgedruckt wird im Endeffekt nur das.
Aber ich meine, was soll es? Was ist das? Ah, das JetBrains Ding. So, ich zeige euch
mal Source Code technisch. Hat sich ein bisschen, was ist mit meiner Platte? Warum ist die? Fuck,
Cash. Jawoll, ich brauche Platz. Zehn Gigabyte nur noch frei. Ich glaube, es hackt. Also,
ich habe das Ganze auch ein bisschen aufgeräumt. Also, wir haben heute mehrere Möglichkeiten,
was wir machen können. Wir können den, ich schreibe mir das mal kurz auf. Also, was wir
heute machen können ist, wir können den, wir können den Icon Browser ausbauen und
zwar habe ich mir überlegt, dass man ja anstatt MDI Icons, habe ich nämlich was gefunden
auf, oh, das mit dem, mit der Scrollbar funktioniert nicht so richtig, dass wir nicht nur Material
Design Icons haben, sondern auch andere Icons. Habe ich auf YouTube was gefunden, nicht auf,
jetzt labere ich ja nicht auf YouTube, man, auf GitHub habe ich was gefunden. Da hat einer
ein JSON-File gemacht für, ich glaube, 20 oder 30 Image-Fonds inklusive Name, Prefix
und SVGs drinne. Das müssen wir eigentlich nur inkluden und das alte rausschmeißen.
Wer war der Hersteller vom Printer, kannst du ja mal promoten. Ne, die Satten, die will
ich nicht promoten. Die bauen DRM in ihre Drucke ein. Die promote ich bestimmt nicht.
Ich hoffe, die kriegen da ihren Shit Together mal wieder. So, wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben?
Also, wir könnten, wir könnten den Icon Browser ausbauen mit mehr Icons. Wir könnten ganz
richtig ein Emoji Browser machen. Warum nicht? Twitchy Modes. Hat, hat FFZ in der AP? Moment.
Moment. Die haben eine, die haben eine E-Mode-AP.
Okay, das finde ich ist eine gute Idee, kann man. Das finde ich, das ist ja nice. Alter,
wer braucht für einen Label-Drucker Twitchy-Modes? Gut, andere Fragen ist eher, wer braucht sie
nicht? Kogas ausdrucken. Das Problem ist animierte GIFs ausdrucken ist schwierig. Das da macht
er so Endlosschleife drin, bis das GIF durch ist. Stellt euch mal vor, das hier als GIF,
der müsste einfach irgendwie 50 Labels ausdrucken für das GIF. So, also das können wir machen.
Also, wir können Twitchy-Modes einbauen, Emoji Browser. Ich würde sagen, wir bauen die Icons
jetzt. Egal, egal, was könnte man machen, habe ich mir überlegt. Wir müssen den QR-Dialog,
QR-Code-Dialog irgendwie noch bauen, weil den gibt es noch nicht. Wenn du einen QR-Code
einfügst, fügt da aktuell einfach ein QR-Code mit Standardtext ein, ohne dass du die Möglichkeit
hast, irgendwas einzufügen. Das ist natürlich doof. Das könnte man aber auch in das Edit-Menü
machen. Mal gucken, bin ich mir noch nicht ganz schlüssig. Wir müssen dem Edit-Menü
auch mal gescheite Icons verpassen, weil aktuell, guck mal, Bold Italic Underline, das hat schlicht
und ergreifend einfach noch keinen Inhalt und es macht auch noch nichts. Dann muss noch
eingebaut werden, ja, das Label-Menü, weil das Label-Menü selbst hat Blutblatt plus
zweimal Testetiketten. Ich glaube, der Drucker unterstützt irgendwie 30 verschiedene Etikettensorten.
Die können wir einfügen. Ich klicke immer auf, ich sollte das machen, wenn ich die selekte.
Das machen wir jetzt mal schnell, das mache ich, weil das nervt mich. Als global, ja ja,
global erst mal. So, wenn es Null ist, dann sagen wir, selekte Tab auch gleich Null, dann
geht das nämlich zu. Also, was genau hat das? Was genau hat das damit zu tun, dass das auf
und nicht aufgeht? What the fuck? Der Zusammenhang erschließt sich mir jetzt nicht. So was wie
Snap to Crit, ja, Snap to Crit ist useless. Brauchen wir nicht. Nee, haben wir doch schon,
Lul. Gebaidet, guck mal. Haben wir doch schon. Snap an Rand und du kannst sogar den Text,
also wenn du den Text in die Mitte haben willst, machst du einfach so, gehst in die Mitte und
dann machst du das Icon in die Mitte unten drunter. Das gibt's schon, habe ich schon
eingebaut. Das gibt's schon, aber offscreen habe ich das eingebaut. Nicht nice. Und es
snappt sogar richtig, Poggers. Poggers Snapper. Nee, Snap ist nicht Pog. Komische Ubuntu
Package Format da. Ja, okay. Also das Labelmenu kommt und ich brauche was. Upload File. Ja,
Moment. Upload File. Den habe ich ja gar nicht. Ist ja gar nicht mehr da. Den habe
ich ja aus Versehen gelöscht. Ja, wir hatten ja mal einen File Icon. MDI File. So was.
Oder File Plus. Offscreen ja, aber File Upload. Wir müssen ja. Moment, das. Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Warum geht. Ach so, weil Name Setup ist. Upload File. Ja, das geht nämlich auch wieder
was Leeres auf, wo es so nichts für gibt. Okay, also File Upload sollten wir machen,
das ist glaube ich nicht verkehrt. Braucht man sonst noch? Also File Upload. Upload ist
zu viel gesagt. Wir Uploaden eigentlich gar nichts. Wir machen ein Button. Eigentlich.
Leute, File Upload. Easy as fuck. Das machen wir jetzt. Das machen wir jetzt zuerst. Dazu
müssen wir nämlich gar nichts machen. Großartig. Name File. Wir müssen nämlich einfach sagen.
Click. On Tap. Click. Upload File. Upload ist dummes, dummes Wort. Insert. Insert File
hier. Insert. Nein. Open File Browser. Das dürfte nämlich total einfach sein. Wie macht
man den JavaScript den Open File Browser? Wie macht man den JavaScript den File Browser
auf? Wie funktioniert dann sowas? Wie geht das? Hab ich eben nicht gemacht. Nee, da braucht
man ein Input. Da braucht man Input Element oder sowas. Open File Dialog. Open File Dialog
Box in JavaScript. Wie geht das? Das muss man mit dem Input machen. Put Input Element
Typ File Anywhere on the Page. Ok, das. Warum? Kann man mir mal erklären, warum ist alles
so unglaublich hacky und geduldig in JavaScript und HTML? Warum kann ich nicht einfach sagen
Open File Dialog und gib mir das File zurück? Warum muss ich den Input verstecken? Geht
das? Geht das vielleicht irgendwie? Programmatically Open File Dialog in JavaScript? Ok. Jakeberry.
Ok, da wissen wir schon. Die machen das wirklich so. Alter, was ist mit Google los? Warum ist
Google so hell? Ok, das scheint nicht zu funktionieren. Einfach so zu openen. Das ist schon ein Pains
Champ. So, und jetzt? Moment. Weiter? Wie ging das jetzt? Jakeberry, Alter. Sekunde.
Guck mal, Stack Overflow. Wenn wir schon auf der richtigen Seite gucken. Ah, Fiveheader.
Create Element Fiveheader Time. Alter, Stack Overflow wieder. Wir machen temporär ein
Input Element, sagen das Input Element ist File, dann klicken wir auf das nicht vorhandene
Input Element. Pock. Mega Fivehead. Mega Fivehead. Ok, und wie kriege ich jetzt mit, wenn da
was klickt wird? Und Change. Ah ja. Easy. Easy. Um nicht zu sagen. Ja, das ist ja wirklich
easy. Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal. Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken. Was passiert
denn jetzt, wenn ich jetzt einen File öffne mit? So, File hinzufügen. Wo Pock? Event.
Change Target Input. Und wo kriege ich jetzt die? Die Files hier? E Punkt Target. Ok.
Target. Mal gucken. Nein. Ach so, Files. Aha. Guck mal, das ist super dynamisch, dass
man nicht mal das Autocomplete erkennt, dass es funktioniert. Tatsächlich funktioniert.
Easy. File. Name. Wo Pock? Image. PNG. So, und jetzt? Ok, ok, also, also. Ich nenne
das mal Event. Da kann ich mir das besser merken. Event. Target. Files. Also, ok. Let. File.
Gleich. Sollen wir abfangen, dass das an irgendwelcher Stelle irgendwie leer ist. Also im Prinzip
müssen wir so machen, dass es leer ist. Wenn da was drin ist. Kann man das irgendwie anders
besser händeln? Ja. So, wenn da, wenn ein File hinzugefügt wurde. Das will ich, brauche
ich was? Ein File Reader wahrscheinlich? Würde ich mal vermuten. Reader. Gleich. New. Reader.
So. Und wie ging das jetzt nochmal? Reader. Read. Nee. Das habe ich doch schon mal oben
irgendwo. File Reader. On Load. Alles klar. Wir klauen uns das einfach mal von hier oben.
Ok. File. File Reader. On Load. Was? Closing Tag. Ah, das gehört da gar nicht. Hä?
Was? Ah, ja. Alles klar. Was auch immer. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok.
Was auch immer. Hä? JavaScript. Ok. File. File Reader. File. Und Reader Reset. Moment,
was mache ich da überhaupt? Read As Data Will File. Geht das jetzt? Geht das einfach
so jetzt? Undefined. Nee, nee. Ok. So einfach geht es nicht. Geht dann überhaupt, geht
dann überhaupt so prinzipiell das Öffnen des Files so? Progress Event. Type Load. Data
Will. Sag mal, mache ich das überhaupt richtig? Muss ich das On Load machen? Oh Mann. Alter,
wie öffnet man das Bild? Moin. Müsste das jetzt nicht so einfach funktionieren, wenn
ich das richtig mache? Ich muss mir mal irgendeine Hilfeseite angucken. Oh, not found. Object.
Moment. Ok. Das muss ich mir. Input File Reader. Wie funktioniert der Krampel? Mozilla weiß
Bescheid. Nein. Gibt keinen. On Load. Ein Handler. Wenn der Lesefolger erfolgreich
beendet wurde, habe ich doch gemacht. Event Target Files Reader. On Load. Ist doch eigentlich
ich mache das doch richtig. Oder mache ich das nicht richtig? Doch, guckt mal, da ist
mein PNG. Ist doch alles ok. Das muss doch so funktionieren. Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Warum geht das nicht? Ach, da ist es doch. Das Bild war hinter dem Scheiß Menü. Das
ging die ganze Zeit schon. Es hat einfach die ganze Zeit funktioniert. Es hat die ganze
Zeit schon funktioniert. Ich habe es wohl nicht gesehen. Ok, nice. Also das ist auf
jeden Fall nicht so clever. Ich glaube, ich verfrachte das hier rein und ansonsten lassen
wir es. Nochmal testen. Woop Pog. Da ist es doch. Woop Pog. Funktioniert. Easy File Upload.
Da brauchen wir gar kein extra Menü oder sonst was. Das ist doch. Woop Pog in schwarz-weiß.
Wie viele Zeilen notwendig sind für eine? Das geht doch. Hier, guck mal. Im Prinzip.
Wobei Upload ist das falsche Wort. Das ist ja rein kleinseitig. Hier sowas da. Das ist
doch gar nicht mal so viel. Das ist doch wirklich überschaubar. Kann man sich jetzt gar nicht
beschweren. Ist doch echt in Ordnung. Wir sollten jetzt vielleicht noch testen, ob das
irgendein Supportedes File ist. Poggers. JPEG. Das Log sollte ich mal unbedingt wieder rausmachen.
Wer kann webp? Das ist ja richtig extrem sophisticated hier. Webp. Dann wollen wir das. Woop Pog.
Ich meine, das müssen wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen schöner machen. Das haben wir
jetzt ziemlich doppelt. Ja. Open File. So, wir sollten noch mal kurz gucken, was das jetzt
eigentlich ist. Sieht man da irgendwo, ob das ein Supportedes File Format ist? Wobei ganz
ehrlich, scheiß doch drauf. Solange es nicht abkackt, wenn ein nicht Supportedes File Format
genommen wird. Was passiert, wenn du ein GIF hochlädst? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Hab ich hier irgendwie ein GIF? Das erste Bild davon macht er. Wie das einfach funktioniert,
ohne dass sich was passiert, wenn ich irgendeinen Shit uploade. Wenn ich keine Ahnung, Tasmota
bin, GZ hochlade, dann macht er einfach nix. Er ist ja okay. Warte mal, fang ich das vielleicht
hier irgendwo ab? Nö, ich mach nirgendswo einen Check. Ich versuche hier Bilder einzufügen
und ich versuche Binaries als Bilder einzufügen und das funktioniert. Ohne Fehler. Also, es
passiert nichts. Aber ohne Fehler. Soll ich mir recht sein? Kann ich mitleben? Vollkommen
in Ordnung. Easy. Das war's. File Upload, fertig. So einfach könnte das immer sein.
Das ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen doppelt, weil Open File Browser und Clipboard Copy
Paste ist jetzt doppelt. Also man könnte eine Funktion machen, so nach dem Motto Read
File, dann könnte man das hier ein bisschen kürzer. Okay, probieren wir es mal aus. Da
könnte man nämlich auch hier drinnen checken. If not file, dann return. Da kann man uns
das nämlich sparen. Und jetzt kommt alles da rein. Read File. Achso. Ja gut, dann sollte
man vielleicht nicht Read File, Insert File oder so nennen. Insert File. Mario Galaxy
Musik. Ja, dann geht das gleich viel besser. Oh ne, Leute, es ist broken. Das ist kaputt.
Warum? Ja, vielleicht soll ich das File noch übergeben. JavaScript, Calc Way, da ist es.
Okay, Wuppok wieder am Start. Sehr schön. Ein nicer Wuppok. So, weil das kann ich nämlich
auch sagen, hier oben, wo ich den Krempel mache mit dem Einlesen, kann ich auch einfach
sagen Insert File, dann ist das viel kürzer und knackiger. Übrigens, ein Feature habe
ich euch noch gar nicht gezeigt. Guckt mal, Copy Paste. Man kann Text Copy Pasten. Jeden
X beliebigen Copy, jeden X beliebigen Text kann man Copy Pasten und einfügen, falls man
das will. So, mal gucken, ob das mit Bildern noch funktioniert. Calc Way, das Calc Way
mit Bildern. Copy Image. Uns noch. Nice. Okay, das ist glaube ich, so einfach habe ich noch
nie File Upload gemacht. Alles klar. Eingefügte Sachen sollten auf die Größe des Canvas skaliert
werden. Also Höhe, Breite will ich nur setzen, wenn es keine, also Höhe, Breite setze ich
prinzipiell nur, wenn es keine Pixel Daten sind. Weil bei Pixel Daten brauche ich das
Original. Also eigentlich müsste ich, wenn es Pixel Daten sind, müsste ich Scale machen.
Nee, ich muss immer Scale machen. Ich muss eigentlich müsste ich immer skalieren. Also
ich meine, wobei SVGs kann ich fest da draufsetzen. SVGs auf 40 40. Das ist okay. Weil ich jetzt
beispielsweise hier irgendwas ein Image einfüge, dann ist es halt 40 mal 40. Das passt eigentlich
ganz gut. Man könnte es runter skalieren. Ja, also quasi Image Scale X und Image Scale
Y. Wir probieren mal was. Wir machen es mal auf 05. Ich will einfach nur mal gucken, ob
das prinzipiell funktioniert, was ich so mache. So Bild einfügen. Wo POG? Ja, nee, das ist
jetzt kleiner als sonst. Okay, ich habe es auf 05 skaliert. So sah es mit 05 Skalierung
aus? Ja, definitiv. Also 05 ist auf jeden Fall sinnvolle Skalierung bei. So, das heißt,
ich müsste dann, habe ich an der Stelle, hat das Image an der Stelle eigentlich schon eine
Höhe und Breite? Das ist da schon eine Höhe und Breite, die funktioniert? Tatsächlich
112. Ja. So Serious Marks Big Brain Time. Ist das irgendeine Challenge? Nö, das ist
keine Challenge. Das ist was für meinen Label Drucker, das ich ordentlich über Webinterface
drucken kann und vielleicht irgendwann auch nochmal andere Leute. Und weil ich schon immer
mal ein bisschen Java grafisch Edit Zeugs machen wollte, muss ich mir mal anzugucken.
Passt das eigentlich ganz gut. Guck mal, wie nice das snappt. Seht ihr das? Wie nice das
snappt in die Mitte und an den an den Guidelines und richtig Pock. Richtig massive Pock. Wenn
Bild Größe Größe Größe Größe als Canvas Größe, dann Bild Höhe auf Canvas Höhe,
hätte ich gesagt. Ja. Oder immer auf 40 mal 40, wobei das nicht so nicht so klar ist.
Also können wir. OK, OK. Also können wir können wir jetzt checken, if Image Größe
Image ist größer als Stage. Nee, das habe ich nirgendswo. Doch Stage Breite Stage Höhe.
Beside sich. Ja, gut, was macht da nichts. Also wenn das Bild größer ist als die Stage
groß ist, das ist es aber überhaupt nicht. Das ergibt gar keinen Sinn. Leute, warum ist
das Moment? Warum ist das Bild denn so fett? Warum ist das Bild überhaupt so pepo fett?
Das Bild ist. Das Bild ist 1000. Das ist 112 mal 112 ist das Bild. Das ist nix. Und
das ist auch mega verpixelt. Daran sieht man, dass das eigentlich gar nicht so groß ist.
Na ja, gut, aber die Moment, die Stage geht ja ran auf Label auf Label Größe. Ich soll
nicht anhand der Stage, ich sollte anhand des Labels gucken. If Label ist die Label
Höhe größer als die Image Größe, dann. Ja, das können wir machen. Also wenn wenn
das Moment Moment, wenn die Image also wenn das Label kleiner ich war übrigens falsch
herum. Wenn das wenn wenn das eingefügte Bild größer ist als das Label, dann wollen
wir es kleiner machen. Also es heißt sowas hier wie Scale. Also quasi Image durch Label
auf. Hoffentlich ergibt das Sinn, was ich da mache. Wartet mal, gib mal Scale aus, ob
das irgendwie passt. Da muss ja null Komma irgendwas jetzt rauskommen. Moment ist falsch
rum oder falsch rum? Falsch rum. Null Komma drei. Okay. Na dann Image Scale. Da bin ich
mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert. Ne Moment, wenn ich das auf die Scale setze. Das ist
ja einfach nur das Verhältnis zwischen Label und Dings. Das alleine wird wahrscheinlich
nichts, nichts, nichts bringen. Oder doch. Was mache ich da eigentlich gerade? Was ist
das für eine Berechnung? Also was ist der Sinn davon? Label Höhe durch Bild.
Da kommt dann das Verhältnis von Label Höhe zu Bild raus und dann skaliere ich das Bild
runter. Das ist quasi in die in die genau in die in das Label passt, oder? Das ist
doch eigentlich eigentlich sogar relativ richtig, was ich hier mache. Quickmuffs. Ja, doch,
das ergibt Sinn. Doch, doch, es ist eigentlich richtig. Die einzige Sache, die wir jetzt
noch testen müssen, wäre. Ich mache das dann Offstream wieder ein bisschen hübscher,
weil wir müssten ja das Gleiche eigentlich noch testen, wenn die wenn die Breite größer
ist als Label Breite. Und dann müssten wir das müsste man es skalieren. Auf die auf
die Breite. Hab ich irgendwas, was mega mega six header ist? Leute, habt ihr? Fällt euch
irgendein Bild ein, was so fett ist? Bettke. Der Screenshot. Das funktioniert. Aber der
war wahrscheinlich auch schon zu hoch. White Papo Happy. Herr Sohn. Das war, wo wir Gesichtserkennung
getestet haben mit der Kamera und irgendjemand meinte, das ist ein wunderbares Bild, um
Gesichtserkennung in einer Kamera zu testen. Aber das funktioniert auch. Was aber ziemlich
blöd ist, weil jetzt funktioniert es beim Clipboard nicht. Also. Nee, doch, es funktioniert
beim Clipboard. Ich benutze die gleiche Funktion beim Einfügen vom Clipboard. Okay, testen
das mal. Das ist relativ breit. Ja, guck mal, es skaliert. Es skaliert genau runter auf
die auf die Höhe vom. Vom Label. Wir können ja mal testen, ob es funktioniert. Wir drehen
das einfach mal um oder dreht einfach mal kurz raus. Ja, funktioniert. Jetzt skaliert
das auf die auf die Breite runter. Ich meine, jetzt ist es zwar größer als das Label,
aber Scheiß drauf. So funktioniert sehr schön. Geht das Ganze auch am Hochkanten? Sehr gute
Frage. Das testen wir jetzt mal. Hochkant des Label. Ja. Fast. Wir müssen jetzt theoretisch
das runter skalieren. Wenn, wenn irgendeine Seite davon rausguckt. Aber das ist quick muffs.
Da habe ich echt keinen Bock drauf jetzt. Ja, also von der Theorie her funktioniert
es. Er stellt halt fest. Okay, es ist höher. Wir passen. Wir passen nur die Höhe an, aber
nicht die Breite. Ja, ich müsste. Ich müsste im Prinzip das machen, was ich beim Zoomen
hier mit dem mit dem Scale auch mache. Also das da. Das da. Sind das das wie so Sticker?
Nee, das ist ein Label Drucker. Moment, ich zeig dir mal hier. Label Drucker. Schau mal.
Wir haben letztes doch ein Stream gemacht, wo wir das, wo wir das im Raspberry Pi zum
Drucken versucht haben, zum zu überreden. Label Printer. Der Label Champ. Dymo Label
Drucker Experiment. Guck, das ist ein Label Drucker. Kropfunkt. Sehr gute Idee. Ich glaube,
sowas baue ich wirklich noch ein. Gropffunktion. Das ist gut. Das ist nämlich richtig praktisch,
weil dann könnte man jetzt auch sagen, wer schneidet die Seiten ab. Das ist ein Label
Drucker. Guck. Und dass ich so Labels nicht in der Finity Designer basteln muss und dann
rüber exportieren als Ding, mache ich mir ein Web Interface mit Label Editor. Qt Street
69. Aber Kropffunktion finde ich tatsächlich sehr sinnvoll. So. Min. Also ich will sowas
hier eigentlich machen. Guck mal. Eigentlich will ich das machen. Maß Min. Image. Und
jetzt nicht Minus 80. Einfach nur so. Image Breite. So, jetzt brauche ich die Quick Mars
Fivehead vom Chat. Moment, das muss. Quick Mars Fivehead vom Chat. Wie geht es weiter?
Hilft mir mal. Ich blicke gerade nicht mehr durch. Gibt es das Backend schon? Naja, das
Backend hier noch nicht, aber ich habe schon mal ein bisschen rumgespielt mit einem.NET
IPP Library. Das Drucken ist tatsächlich ziemlich simpel. So, Scale. Und jetzt mache
ich einfach nur so, oder? Chat, wenn ich das jetzt richtig, theoretisch mache ich einfach
nur so. Und dann müsste es funktionieren. Nee. Oh, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow. Nee. Moment.
Log. Scale. Was ist jetzt das Problem? Mach ich das falsch rum? Ich will runter skalieren.
Schon besser. So, wo ist mein Kekwe Image? Aha. Moment, hochkant das Label. Funktioniert.
Guckt. Er macht das Bild jetzt in klein. Jetzt können wir ein komplettes horizontales.
Ah, Copy Paste funktioniert nicht, sehe ich gerade. Damit. Also man kann nicht doppelt
Copy Pasten. Interessante Sache. Jetzt ein komplett horizontales KekW Label machen. Ich
brauche mal hier Beach. Ich brauche ein bisschen High-Res Bild, Leute. High-Res. Wie groß ist
das? 1000. Perfekt. Mal gucken, ob das mit dem Zoom funktioniert. Ja, guck mal. Das ist
ziemlich High-Res, das Bild. Ich bin richtig nah rangezoomed und es wird nicht pixelig.
Der benutzt die höchste Auflösung, wenn er sie braucht und sie vorhanden ist. Okay,
das funktioniert. Das ist doch eigentlich sehr, sehr nice. Ja, da gibt es eigentlich
jetzt nichts mehr weiter hinzuzufügen. Not found. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen darf ich
die Dinger nicht Copy Pasten, was auch immer. Aber es funktioniert. Ich glaube, das kann
man jetzt erstmal dabei lassen. Ach so, was mache ich, weil ich doch bescheuert bin.
Das muss ich immer machen. Wofür ist das für meinen Label Drucker? Dass ich Label
designen kann. Aha, die Filter nimmt er nicht mit. Fivehead oder auch besserer, besserer,
nicht Fivehead. Also man sieht, das hat schon noch so ein paar kleine Bugs. Schreibe einfach
ein. Die Sachen, die immer nicht... Schreibe einfach Fix me rein und fixen das nie. Copy
Paste. From Copy Paste ist kaputt. Wenn man was rein Copy Pasted hat, dann hast du noch
mal Copy Pasted funktioniert nicht. Das ist aber nur was kleines. Wahrscheinlich, weil
ich die Filter hier unten setze und hier beim Insert dann keine Filter mitgebe oder so.
Bzw. ich die Filter nicht serialisiere beim Copy Paste. Das muss ich mir angucken. Genau,
in den Backlog für nächsten Sprint. Easy. Fertig. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das hier
hin muss. Okay, aber jetzt machen wir mal was Sinnvolles. Lang genug daran rum gewurstet
an der Stelle jetzt. Okay, also machen wir mal was Sinniges. Also was haben wir jetzt
zur Auswahl? Ja, erstellt mir mal ein Ticket. Genau. Weird Champ. Oder schreibt mich mal
ein Teams an. So. Gut. Wunderbar. Team Smokey. Hast du dafür auch einen Change erstellt?
Ja. Ihr wart halt nicht zum Daily Stand Up heute da. Kann ich ja nichts dafür, dass
ihr das nicht mitgekriegt habt. Ihr wisst doch, wie das ist. Informationen muss man sich
holen. Informationen bekommt man nicht. Nachdem keiner von euch heute beim Stand Up war, habt
ihr das natürlich auch alle nicht mitgekriegt. Da kann ich ja nichts für. So ist das halt
im Business Enterprise Umfeld. Also wir haben jetzt einen File Upload Dialog gemacht. Was
machen wir denn jetzt davon? Chat, noch mal eine Frage an euch. Hat irgendeiner noch eine
praktische Idee? Sollen wir vorbeikommen? Nee. Man kann sowas auch Remote machen. Wir
machen jetzt im Discord, wenn es so weiter geht im Discord, machen wir Daily Stand Up.
Nein, bloß nicht. Daily Sprint Meeting. Wenn es eine Kropffunktion hat, auch eine Rotation.
Eine Rotationsfunktion hat das schon. Guck. Text. Achtung. Rotaten kann es schon. Und
das kann ich nur rotieren. Guck mal. Passt mal auf. Habe ich ja noch gar nicht erzählt.
Der Snappt. Der Snappt die Rotation. Guck mal. Seht ihr das? Der Snappt die Rotation. Also
wenn ich jetzt so bin und es nicht ganz gerade hab. Gibt es Snap to Grid schon? Ja, sowas
ähnliches. Guck mal. Kannste es in der Mitte ausrichten. Dann fügst du ein Icon hinzu
und dann kannst du das Icon hier auch in der Mitte ausrichten. Oder auch nicht. Ja. Exportieren,
importieren. Ja, das machen wir auf jeden Fall. Das muss ich auch gar nicht aufschreiben,
weil das kommt eh. Also dass du das Ding speichern und laden kannst, das bleibt ja nicht die
einzige Seite hier. Das ist ja nur der Editor davon. Gut. Dann machen wir jetzt mal was
sinniges. Also Serientruck anbieten aus einer CSV. Ne, außer CSV garantiert nicht. Aber
was ich mir überlegt habe ist, man könnte eine API machen, über die du drucken kannst.
Machst du ein Curl Request? Machst du ein Curl Request mit Label ID? XML, alter Leute,
was ist mit euch los? Piss dich, Aldo. Kommt als nächstes Soap Request anstatt irgendwas
mit Jason oder Backending Kobold oder was? Hast du eine Empfehlung für einen Switch?
Ja, habe ich. Wie heißt das Ding? Ok. Wie heißt das Ding nochmal? Egal. 4S plus, findet
man ihn auch. Den da. CHS3051G4S plus IN. Obvious, Leute. Warum wusstet ihr das nicht?
Switch, den meine ich. Der ist gut. 4 Ports, 10 Gigabit, ein 1 Gigabit Management Port.
Also musst du nicht als Management Port verwenden. Kannst du auch für alles andere verwenden.
Aber kannst du halt den Switch auch über PoE betreiben. Dual Netzwerk. Äh, ich weiß
nicht. Dual Netzteil Anschluss, also redundantes Netzteil oder PoE oder ein 1 Gigabit Management
Interface oder ganz normales 1 Gigabit Interface und 4x SFP plus 10G für. Das Ding ist relativ
günstig. Haltet euch fest. 450 Euro. Der CHS326 ist Oversized. Er will 4 Ports. Der
hat nämlich 24 und plus 2 10 Gigabit. Er will 14 Gigabit haben. Haben Kupfer? Ja, also
wenn du diese Direct Attach Kabel haben, eine deutlich schlechtere Reichweite. Die Direct
Attach Kabel gehen, glaube ich, offiziell, bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, 10 Meter oder
so. Ohne aktive Verstärkung. Direct Attach Max Range. 10 Meter, ja. Also, im Prinzip kann
man sagen, die einfachste und billigste Variante, 10 Gigabit miteinander zu verbinden, sind
Direct Attach Kabel. Und 10 Meter reicht ja meistens aus, solange man sich in der Nähe
vom Serverraum befindet. Ja, vom Büro zum Serverraum oder vielleicht vom Büro zum Wohnzimmer
rüber geht das noch. Alles andere im Haus musst du dann entweder per ganz normalem
AJ45 Ethernet Kabel machen oder wenn es richtig, richtig weit sein muss, dann bleibt dir außer
Glasfaser wahrscheinlich nicht viel übrig. Also wenn du ein Kabel brauchst, an deinen
Switch oben im ersten Stock, in deine Gartenhütte auf deinem 800 Quadratmeter Grundstück, ja,
dann wird's schwierig. Und wenn du das Ganze natürlich auch noch mit 10 Gigabit brauchst.
Kennt ihr noch das Video, was wir letztens geguckt haben? Der Typ mit dem ultra teuren
Ethernet Kabel, wo wir uns am Ende des Videos gefragt haben, warum hieß das Video so? Das
hatte mit dem Inhalt überhaupt nichts zu tun. Das stimmt. Aber die funktionieren. Zumindest
die, die ich hab, funktionieren ganz gut. Es ist halt stromfressender, ja. Also die beste
Variante ist tatsächlich Attached Kabel. Wenn's ausreicht, ja. So geht's, ja. Alles
klar. Also ich weiß mit Acha und Krach, dass der BVB ist irgendein Fußballverein, der
glaube ich ganz gut ist. Und ansonsten Fußball, MonkaS, alter. Keine Ahnung. Q drucken lassen,
ja. Ach so. Nee, das ist kein Problem. Das handelt der Server alles schon. Letztendlich
hast du ja eine Drucker-Warteschlange auf der Server-Seite dann. Da muss ich nichts
für machen. Aber wie gesagt, man könnte eine Druck-AP anbieten, dass ich sag, schick mir
ein Call-Request und schick die Label-ID mit. Und wenn man richtig, richtig advanced irgendwann
ist, könnte man zum Beispiel sowas machen, dass man sich ein Label zusammenstellt. Sag
mal, das ist jetzt mein mega, mega nice Label. Ja, so soll das Label immer aussehen. Aber
ich kann diesen Text oder den QR-Code als Template markieren und dann über die Call-AP
noch den Inhalt austauschen oder so. Das ist aber super advanced, ja. Da könnte man nämlich
quasi auch Call-Requests schicken, um irgendwelche, keine Ahnung, Eintrittspässe oder WLAN-Zugangsdinger
oder so auszudrucken. Das wäre natürlich pock. Aber das mach ich irgendwann mal, wenn
der Kram funktioniert, ja. Kann man Emojis nicht über die Textfunktion eingeben? Probieren
wir mal, was passiert, wenn ich Emojis einfüge. Also ich würde ja mal vermuten, es geht allerdings
nur schwarz-weiß. Äh. Wie? Das geht einfach. Ja, ja, wie geht's?
Ja, ja, wie das denn? Warum geht das einfach? Die Emojis sehen aber in Firefox bestimmt
anders aus. Schauen wir mal. Aha. Oh Leute, im Firefox ist das Copy-Paste kaputt. Ah,
geh weg. Ah, wie krieg ich das wieder? Äh, im Firefox ist das Copy-Paste kaputt. Das funktioniert?
Aber Emojis Copy-Pasten funktioniert im Firefox nicht. Emojis kopieren geht im Firefox nicht
aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Ich hab's kopiert. Geht nicht. Emojis sind OS-abhängig. Naja,
das ist das gleiche, OS. Aber du siehst, dass es Unterschiede gibt zwischen dem Rendering.
Der hier nimmt diese Mozilla Emojis und der hier nimmt meinen Emoji-Font, den ich auf
dem System erzählt hab. Aber warum geht das Copy-Paste da nicht richtig? Shift-drücken?
Was? Shift-v? Nee. Es funktioniert nur, wenn ich über den Umweg von diesem Textfeld mach.
Funktioniert's ja auch. Leute, wisst ihr, dass das ultra nice ist, dass das funktioniert?
Aber das Editieren ist schon etwas, etwas broken, ne? Mit Emojis. Ah, das ist ein Bug,
der entfernt das Element, wenn ich, wenn ich im Input entfernen drück. Das liegt gar nicht
da dran, dass es verbackt ist. Wenn ich das so mach und Leer-Zeich drück, dann geht's.
Lul. Ja, cool. Nice. Moment, jetzt geht das Copy-Paste? Alter Firefox, ich versteh den
nicht. Das UI ist mittlerweile richtig cool, ja. Advanced. Ja, ach übrigens, also wisst
ihr, warum das richtig nice ist, dass das mit den Emojis funktioniert? Weil, dann brauch
ich kein, wobei doch Leute, ich brauch ein Emoji-Browser. Ich will, eigentlich will
ich Twitter-Emojis haben. Ach, scheiß drauf. Wurscht. Das passt so. Wenn man Emojis einführen
kann, ist alles gut. Ich meine ja Twitch-Emojis, nicht Twitter. Quatsch, was laber ich denn?
Ich meine Twitter-Emojis, nicht Twitch-Emojis. Alter, meinst du, das ist ja heute ganz schlimm.
Benutzst du Fabric.js? Nee, das ist Convert.js. Und die sagen, sie wollen explizit, wollen
keine Inline-Edit-Funktion haben. Man soll ein Overlay, man soll ein Overlay, eine Overlay-Textbox
machen. Was ist nicht Schlimmes? Ich meine, man kann den Kram hier editieren. Ich glaube,
das wird man verkraften. Okay, weiter, weiter im Text. Also, da hat sich das mit dem Emoji-Editor
erst mal erledigt. Was haben wir gerade für einen Bug gefunden? Nee, gar keinen, oder?
Hat doch alles funktioniert. Egal, das kriegen wir schon noch raus. Ach, entfernen. Ja, ja,
ich weiß sogar. Backspace? Ja, Backspace. So, das hier, das hat einen Bug, weil das
global geht. Also, muss ich gucken? Also, was mache ich jetzt nicht? Backspace in edit
input löscht. Gut, ich will jetzt irgendwas sinniges noch einbauen von den Sachen hier
oben. Also, das Label-Menü ist ziemlich langweilig, weil da müsste man einfach hier mehrere Labels
reinschreiben. Ich glaube, das kann ich mal offstream machen. Emoji-Browser hat Twitch-Emoji-Modes,
könnte man machen. Oder mehr Icons in den Icon-Browser. Ich glaube, wir machen mal
erst mal mehr Icons in den Icon-Browser. File-Upload haben wir schon gemacht. File-Upload funktioniert.
Kein Ding. Wupp-Bett. Zack. Das funktioniert mittlerweile richtig gut, muss ich sagen.
Da hätte ich vor einer Woche auch nicht gedacht. Vorlagen speichern? Ja, speichern muss ich
mir aber erst mal überlegen, weil die Sachen will ich ja serverseitig speichern. Und ich
habe noch keinerlei Backend am Start. Außer das Standard-Projekt-Template. Speichern dürfte
von der Idee her aber relativ simpel sein, weil wir können das ja mal ausprobieren.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich mache jetzt mal einen extra Icon zum Ausprobieren. Das bleibt dann
zwar nicht, aber ok. Save. Was gibt es denn für ein gutes Material-Design-Icon für File-Speichern?
Die Seite ist immer wahnsinnig geschwind. Huge Speed.
Wie ist so dein Fazit zu Zveld? Finde ich richtig nice. Ich hätte die Seite auch ohne
Probleme mit Vue.js machen können. Und wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein bisschen einfacher, weil so
manche Sachen hat halt Zveld nicht. Zum Beispiel keine dynamischen Slots und sowas, die gerade
für Tab-Komponenten oder Tabellen ganz praktisch sind. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das wirklich
nice. Also kannst beides ohne Probleme verwenden. Was hat das hier mit Save zu tun? Der hat
alles geladen gerade. Was meinst du mit dynamischen Slots? Dass du sowas machen kannst.
Wo habe ich denn Slots? Hier. Dass du sowas machen kannst. Das geht nicht. Name cannot
be dynamic. Das funktioniert nicht. In Vue kannst du das machen und das ist in manchen
Fällen tatsächlich ganz praktisch. Zum Beispiel, ich zeige euch das mal auf Vue.js data-table.
Für solche Sachen ist das ganz praktisch. Wenn man zum Beispiel, wie Kalorien gerendert
werden, customisieren will, dann hättest du einen Name-Slot für Kalorien, der aber
dynamisch erzeugt wird, je nachdem, was der Inhalt von der data-table ist. Das kannst
du mit Vue machen, aber das ist eines der Grenzfälle, wo das sinnvoll ist. Das kannst
du mit Svelte nicht machen. Svelte musst du wahnsinnig rumtrixen mit irgendwelchen Component-Maps
oder sonst was und das kriegst du nicht so schön hin. Was ich auch doof finde bei Svelte
ist, dass du sowas nicht standardmäßig machen kannst. Du kannst standardmäßig keine Komponenten
stylen, weil das nicht weiter gereicht wird. Das kannst du nur machen, wenn du selbst einen
Export hast mit Klasse. Ich weiß woran das liegt. Das liegt daran, weil in Vue ist es
so, dass eine Komponente immer maximal ein Top-Level-Element haben darf, in Svelte ist
das nicht so. Auf der anderen Seite, man könnte ja alles in ein Diff rappen oder so. Das machen
die bei manchen anderen Sachen ja auch. Das finde ich auch ein bisschen blöd, dass das
nicht geht. Alles in allem ist das aber äußerst angenehm. Das sind aber so Dinge, die braucht
man auch nicht oft. Ich finde das wirklich nice. Was haben wir denn für ein schönes
Icon? Gibt es Beautify? Nein, die sind mega langsam. Die haben jetzt irgendeine Roadmap
oder so. Ja, die haben noch Beta. Ich glaube demnächst wollen sie es angeblich haben. Mai,
nächsten Monat. Ich finde es blöd, dass man es selbst machen muss. Hier habe ich es ja
auch gemacht. Man kann ja einfach so etwas hier sagen. Ich finde es aber blöd, dass
man das machen muss. Übrigens ein Punkt mit Name Slots, warum das cool wäre, weil ich
weiß nicht, ob das ein gutes Beispiel für ist. Nee, ist es nicht. Egal. Machen wir mal
irgendwas. Weiter. Wir machen jetzt mehr Icons in den Icon Browser, weil wir sind uns einig,
oder? Das Leute sind eindeutig zu wenige Icons zur Auswahl. Das müssen unbedingt mehr
sein, mehr Icons. Ich wollte euch zeigen, dass man das einfach saveen kann. Hier, brauchen
wir ein halbwegs sinniges Save Icon. Chat, was ist das schönste Save Icon hiervon? Eigentlich
finde ich die alle nicht schön. Die sehen alle kacke aus. Was ist Material Design und
schönes Save Icon? Habt ihr da irgendwie Pfeil? Vielleicht was mit Pfeil? Sackt alles, Alter.
Diskette. Content Save. Also das. Naja, also ich will euch immer noch zeigen, dass das
mit dem Save theoretisch relativ easy geht. On, Tab, Klick. Save. Das mache ich gleich
wieder weg. Ich will euch bloß mal zeigen. Und zwar man kann save. Man kann sagen, man
will einfach sagen Stage to Object ist es, glaube ich. Ganz sicher. Dann klickst du
auf save. Dann exportiert er dir deine komplette Stage als JavaScript Object. Das kannst du
Jason stringifyen und speichern. Und dann kannst du es wieder laden. Das dürfte tatsächlich
relativ easy sein. Es gibt ein paar Sachen, wo man aufpassen muss. Beispielsweise, dass
der Event Listener nicht attached. Deswegen habe ich überhaupt nirgendswo Event Listener
verwendet. Außer bei der Stage selbst. Da muss ich mir irgendwie so eine Load Funktion
bauen für die Komponente. Das kriege ich schon noch gebacken. Oh. Ich bin übrigens
auch nicht so ganz damit zufrieden, wie das im UI ist. Die Emojis können auch in Tabs
kategoriert werden. Das sind ja keine Emojis. Das sind Material Design Icons. Haben die
auch eine Kategorie? Haben die auch verschiedene Kategorien? Dann könnte man das machen. Zumindest
was mir auch nicht gefällt ist, da muss ich mir etwas anderes einfallen lassen. Also
ich habe es jetzt ja aktuell so gemacht. Das hier fügt Text ein. Das hier fügt Icons
ein. Das hier fügt QR Codes ein. Hier kannst du Dateien hochladen. Das sind quasi alles
Editier-Elemente. Und das da rechts ist als Edit-Menü für die einzelnen Sachen, die
man gerade angeklickt hat. Das passt. Settings und Save passt irgendwie nicht so richtig schön
an diese Stelle in das Menü rein. Genauso sollte ich mal was für Duplicate haben oder
vielleicht wirklich mal sowas wie vorwärts, rückwärts oder so. Ich weiß aber nicht,
wo ich die Icons hinpacken soll ehrlich gesagt. Weil ich meine, ich habe hier nur eine Menüleiste.
Hier oben die Menüleiste ist letztendlich zur Navigation. Ne Top Bar geht nicht. Top
Bar kommen andere. Das hier ist ja nur der Editor. Hier in den Top Bar kommen Links
zu anderen Seiten rein. Das bringt da nichts. Das muss entweder unten rein oder woanders.
Ne, ne, ne. Ihr meint ihr Leute. Ihr meint ihr, ich wäre nicht selbst auf die Idee gekommen,
das in Header zu platzieren. Aber das funktioniert nicht. Ne, du kannst es nicht in Header machen,
weil hier kommen dann sowas halt andere Menüs hin. Von Drucker hinzufügen bis sonst was.
Das bringt nichts. Ne, noch ne, noch ne Leiste. Ich mein, ich hab, theoretisch hab ich genug
Platz, ne. Für, für noch ne. Ach, vielleicht lass ich die, lass ich die Dinge erstmal
da. Mann. Oder wir machen sie auch rechts hin. Dann mach eine Feilfunktion, die man
nach oben wischen kann. Ach, meinst du so, oder wir können so ein Floating Menü irgendwie
hin machen. Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht. Floating Bar für Kontrollelemente. Ja und
wo floatet die dann? Irgendwo hier beim Element oder? Ich hab mir auch schon überlegt, ob
ich das hier floaten lassen soll neben dem Element, aber das ist einfach zu viele, zu
viele Options, ja. Das wird nichts. Aber neben dem Element, Settings und Dings. Vielleicht
neben dem Label. Vielleicht neben dem Label. Weil letztendlich speichert man das Label
und macht Label-Settings. Ach, ich weiß nicht, da muss ich mir noch was überlegen. Wir machen
jetzt mal, wir machen jetzt mal mehr, mehr, mehr Icons noch rein, ja. Das, das will ich
mal ausbringen, weil ich hab nämlich was gefunden. Oder eine zweite Hanna bar. Ja,
das könnte man machen, aber ich glaube, das wird, ich will das halt so easy as fuck haben,
wie geht. Ich will dann nicht noch mehr Navigationselemente und Sachen. Ich weiß nicht, da muss ich mir
was überlegen. Das gefällt mir, das gefällt mir so nicht. Ich mein, was man auch machen
könnte ist, dass man dieses Edit-Menü gar nicht irgendwo hin macht, dass es nur aufgeht
bei Doppelklick oder bei Tab auf dem Tab, aber das ist auch blöd, weil dann weißt du
nicht, dass es das gibt. Ach, muss ich mir was überlegen. Scheiß drauf. Warum ich das
mit den Icons machen will ist folgendes. Ich hab nämlich was gefunden auf GitHub. Da hat
sich irgendeiner hingesetzt und hat so gut wie alle Image-Fonds, zeig euch das so gut
wie alle Image-Fonds, hat er in Jason Format umgewandelt. Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel
Hero-Icons will, kann man hier reingucken und er hat alle Icons da drin. Das heißt im Prinzip
es macht das alle anderen Icons obsolete, weil das einfach alles in allem ist. Und was
ich mir überlegt hab, was wir machen könnte ist, man könnte den Icons-Selektor ein bisschen
umbauen. Aktuell macht der Icons-Selektor ja relativ easy Mode. Der ist so, das ist
nicht lang, 56 Zeilen. Hält sich in Grenzen. Der importiert alle Material-Design-Icons und
dann filtert er hier oben. Man kann jetzt zum Beispiel noch Error oder so suchen. Man
könnte das eins zu eins so lassen, wie es jetzt ist, nur dass ich als Datengrundlage
den Material-Design-Icon, also die Material-Design-Icons rausschmeiße und dafür diese Icon-Fonds Jason
verwende. Das gibt es sogar in NPM, haben die glaube ich sogar. Hier guck mal. NPM install.
Ich hab übrigens immer noch nicht verstanden. Vielleicht pikt das jemand von euch. Warum
Minus Minus Safe? Warum steht das bei, also ich sehe Minus D bei manchen, bei manchen
sehe ich Minus Minus Safe. Minus D ist glaube ich zu sagen, das ist irgendwie Dependency
oder sowas. Aber was ist Minus Minus Safe? Ich meine das Saved ist doch auch, wenn ich
nicht Minus Minus Safe sag. Versteh ich nicht. Solche Floating Apps meinst du? Ja, die Idee
ist natürlich nicht schlecht. Da könnte man theoretisch die ganze Geschichte floating
lassen. Safe stammt glaube ich aus der History und ist mittlerweile obsolet. Okay. Na geil.
Was jetzt? Ups. Guck mal mal. Ob die das schon hinschreiben. Minus Minus Safe. Steht da
gar nicht mehr drin oder was? Warum steht da keine Options? Was ist das für eine Manpage?
Also ich guck Help Help. Alles klar. Help Help. NPM Help. Ach leck mich. Ja was Krippgedöns.
Wen juckts. Links bei der Suche ein Dropdown, wo man selektieren kann, welche Itemfonts man
durchsuchen will. Das ist eine gute Idee. Das gefällt mir. Das schreibe ich mir auf,
das machen wir dann. Nämlich Dropdown, welche Fonts. Wobei, man kann ja eh suchen. Ich meine,
wenn du hier nach nach Arrows suchst und durch scrollst, nimmst du halt den, der dir am besten
gefällt. Im Endeffekt. Ich will jetzt erstmal schauen, wie der Kampel funktioniert. Wir
machen das jetzt mal mehr. Aber das ist eine gute Idee mit dem Dropdown. Das gucken wir
mal. Also Eigenfonts haben wir jetzt installiert. Und dann muss man was machen? Locate. Kekwade.
Hier wird nichts, hier wird nichts locatet. Mal Import und guck mal, was es so gibt. Import.
Prom. Ne. Ah, ich muss bestimmt neu starten, dass der Kampel funktioniert. Wobei ne, das
muss ich zu dir code, das muss ich nicht neu starten. Instagram. Iconify. Ach so, muss ich
wahrscheinlich machen. Slash. Und dann. Und wie greift man dann drauf zu? Der Preser rief
nach. Wäre es nicht JavaScript geworden, würde ich heute Webseiten mit Basics machen. Ich
hab mal. Als ich klein war, habe ich ein Basics. Ich glaube, es war noch Basics 6. Microsoft
Ding in Studio dazu zum Rumklicken war ein Kurs gemacht. Und wisst ihr, was wir in diesem
Kurs gemacht haben? Da waren wir richtig jung noch. Wir haben auf den wir haben ein Sicherheits
Kopie von Half Life 1 mitgebracht, haben da Multiplayer gespielt auf den Rechnern dort.
Und die Lehrerin hat sich gelangweilt, weil wir keinen Bock hatten. Weil wir lieber spielen
wollten. So ist das halt, wenn das mit Kinders macht. Also wie kriegen wir denn jetzt irgendwelche
Icons rein? Kequeit. Ich will nicht lockaten. Ich will einfach hinzufügen. Okay, was haben
ich sagen? Das ist ich habe die Imports und Tags immer noch nicht immer noch nicht gecheckt.
Wieso nenne ich es nicht einfach, so wie das da heißt? Und habe ich jetzt alle Icons da
gecheckt. Einfach immer alles Konsole locken. Modul, Default, Präfix, Info, Icons. Tatsächlich
da ist es. Nice. Bist du noch DevOps der Vorberuf? Ja, das was ich hier mache hat mit meinem Beruf
nicht wirklich viel zu tun. So, dann brauchen wir Material Design Icons. MDE? MDE Lite?
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen MDE und MDE Lite? Iconify, mal bei denen auf die Webseite
gucken. Bros Icons. Lite? Sag mal, warum gibt es eigentlich Google Material Icons und Material
Design Icons? Also was ich daraus erkennen kann, ist, dass das hier von irgendeinem Fan
Projekt ist und das hier die offiziellen sind. Aber warum? Oder sind die hier noch zusätzlich
dazu? Ist quasi Material Design da jetzt das da plus das da? Nee, das ist MDE. Ja, Lite
meine ich nicht. Lite ist das hier unten. Das ist wieder was ganz anderes. Warum gibt
es Material Design Icons und Google Material Icons? Wenn sogar Google Material Icons mehr
hat als Material Design Icons. Was ist denn der Unterschied? Ich kann nur raten so nach
dem Motto hier ist die Lizenz anders oder so. Also das hier scheinen die offiziellen
Google Icons zu sein. Wie auch immer. Ich gehe auch mal davon aus, die schauen anders
aus. Aber sollte Material Icon nicht Material Icon sein? Keine Ahnung. So, also dann probieren
wir das doch mal aus. Wir stellen das jetzt mal um von Material Icons zu einer Suche,
die Material Icons und Hero Icons kann. Oder machen wir mal nur Hero Icons, dass wir sehen,
dass es funktioniert. Also wie bauen wir das denn jetzt um? So ich habe jetzt hier
meine Hero Icons und da drin ist Modul. Mh. Mh. Mh. Mh. Mh. Mh. Mh. Mh. Mh. Mh. Mh. Mh.
Ok ich meine wir können das ja erstmal austauschen einfach. Also die Material Design Icons tauschen
wir mal aus durch die Hero Icons. Und jetzt ist broken. Direkt? Ist auch gut. Würde lieber
so machen import icons from und dann und dann habe ich dann gibt es icons mehrfach das ist
ja auch nicht sinn und zweck der sache oder das bringt ja nichts was ich will doch das
ganze modul guck mal natürlich will ich das ganze modul ich will alles ich will ja den
browser mit über die icons machen also brauche ich alles so uns das was ich hier mache die
fall ha ah ok icons muss ich da noch rausholen ok oder meinst du das hier sind die icons drin ok
ja aber das kann ich doch nicht beim import machen oder geht das auch beim import das heißt ich
müsste dann sowas hier machen import icons es geht das so ich musste ja ok ok ja das ist
tatsächlich das ist dann tatsächlich besser wenn das funktioniert und was bekomme ich hier
jetzt als erstmal ein fehler das fehler ist immer nice gg jetzt ach guck mal jetzt kriege ich
direkt ok das heißt jetzt kann ich hier die icons weglassen mal gucken ob ich das auch wirklich haben
will so so also icons werden nicht geladen weil nee ich will nicht nur die icons haben wobei
will ich nur die eigens haben moment hier auch icons doch guck mal was da rauskommt hier auch
icons und dann will ich jetzt sowas haben wie ach guck mal alter ist das mittlerweile feife hat
er sogar autocomplete für sowas wo hat er das denn her richtig poc g alter poc g jetzt kann man
nicht aussprechen poc g poc body brauche ich gleich ok also will ich hier sowas haben wie
hero icons moment icon icon icon select select icon alles egal hero icons icon und dann body
oder und dann ist ok alles gut oh nee monkeys das muss ich jetzt einmal hier rein machen das
ist der komplette fahrt der ist schon da alles klar ah ich glaube das html davor machen dass
der das als html rendert das sind die icons er guckt das haben wir zusätzliche icons zum
material design if els schleife ich bin mir bei so chatnachrichten immer nicht sicher ob das
ist oder ob das ernst gemeint ist aber ich mein klar ist schleifen ist natürlich das beste
feature von javascript nur javascript kann if schleifen wahrscheinlich kann das javascript
tatsächlich irgendwie ergibt zwar keinen sinn aber es ist javascript in javascript ergibt
einiges keinen sinn gut das einfügen funktioniert natürlich an der stelle jetzt nicht vor und
weil schleifen sind was für eine if weilschleife das habe ich auch nicht gehört ist sowas sollte
ich mal erfinden if weil das wird das würde dann irgendwie so aussehen keine ahnung hat
javascript überhaupt sowas weil if weil sowas da kannst du nämlich das feifert alter so
da kannst du hier sagen if true weil i kleiner 10 das hat die welt gebraucht ich glaube ich
glaube wir machen unsere eigene programmiersprache demnächst einfach nur weil ich weil ich eine
if weil eine if if weilschleife brauche python hat vor els ja aber in python ist es tatsächlich
relativ clever gemacht dass es das nur nach dem kompletten erfolgreichen durchlaufender
schleife ausführt was ich übrigens ein feature finde was andere programmiersprachen auch
nehmen könnten das ist doch eine du weil die du weil wäre ja einmal durchlaufen am ende
das gibts nicht hier sowas schwachsinn select icon was mache ich denn da icon ich bin mir
da gar nicht mehr sicher was was übergebe ich denn da eigentlich den den name oder den
name übergebe ich da ja gut das funktioniert nicht ok leute also das mit hero icons funktioniert
das ist schonmal gut das heißt wir können jetzt mdi leute was machen wir für icons was
haben die für icons jetzt was gibts hier für icons jetzt remix tabler icons unicorn icons
ohja die brauchen wir ja das ist wichtig alle unicorn icons warum sind das unicorn icons
aber die haben einen guten namen den den den das brauche ich auch unicorn icon was davon
ist unicorn icons uel ok uel unicorn icons die wollte ich schon immer haben fluent haben
die die fluent ui Microsoft krempel ok ich wills einfach nur mal testen das reicht jetzt
fluent icons ok prog so jetzt müssen wir uns da irgendwie ne liste draus machen also sagen
wir mal sowas wie hier let icon registry wenn schon gleich das ganze bisschen auf dicke
hose benennen function add icons to registry icons set so und dann rufen wir das so auf
zack fluent icons unicorn icons also ich will das so aufrufen ob das dann funktioniert müssen
wir mal gucken hero icons so was bauen wir da draus jetzt wozu haben wir überhaupt eine
icon registry haben wir das überhaupt warum ein einfaches array soll es doch eigentlich
auch tun oder ich wollte gerade sagen wir können einfach pushen oder wir können wir
können einfach pushen wir brauchen diesen graben doch gar nicht wobei wobei sagt man
gar nicht dass wir das nicht brauchen in welchem format sind die dinger denn doch nee oder
nee das ist ein array da gibt es keine konflikte da wartet mal doch wir brauchen da noch mehr
infos weil in der schleife zum anzeigen muss ich doch wissen woher ich den graben hole
hier drinnen weiß ich weiß doch gar nicht wo es herkommt oder steht es bei icon mit
dabei oh mein browser kackt ab shit ich gebe gerade auf der ich gebe gerade in der konsole
alle 11.000 fluent icons aus das das war schlecht immer auf reload browser please nicht abkacken
ok ich mache lieber wieder zu wir nehmen hier icons die ist ein bisschen kleiner in welchem
format ist es denn ist doch eigentlich ist doch alles da ist doch top das passt doch
das müsste doch passen das heißt ich brauche doch diesen krempel hier gar nicht ich bin
ich bin verwirrt müssen sie sich einfach auch so gehen moment was genau steht denn
hier in icon jetzt eigentlich drinnen was genau steht denn hier in icon eigentlich
drinnen der name warum leute warum ist da nur der name drin angeblich ist da doch noch
body und sonst was mit drinnen was ist bei gleichen icon namen das ist nicht schlimm
weil das ein array ist und kein kein objekt oder keine map da sind doppelte namen kein
problem das wird ja mit index angesprochen warum sind in icon das verstehe ich nicht
und ich schanke was macht schank filtert icons moment was mache ich denn hier deswegen ok
das ist low iq was ich hier mache das ist low iq das das das brauchen wir nicht also
wir müssen das filtern moment wie kriegen wir das hin objekt keys weil ich hole ja explizit
nur die namen raus ich will doch gar nicht nur die namen ich will doch eigentlich alle
alter kannst du mal hier unten bleiben clear console und jetzt blinke ich dann mal durch
hier wo ikons am moment das kann man gar nicht iteraten warum nicht ok da war doch so was
also push also icon registry push und dann kann man da irgendwie eine schleife drüber
machen vor ihr vor each oder sowas ne vor vor oft haben wir da vor oft javascript kram
keine ahnung key moment wie geht das jetzt was gibt er jetzt
was haben wir dazu auswahl caller create das dinger frozen key keys ja das kenne ich das
habe ich schon ausprobiert name seal to string values macht denn values ist wahrscheinlich
das gegenteil von keys vermute ich mal from entries entries brauchen eine hilfe return
an array of key values oft was ich probiere ich will eine liste mal ich will ein array
machen mit allen ikons drin allerdings nicht nur den name sondern halt alles entries so
zero ikons was passiert jetzt aha ok kann ich da kann man da irgendwie sowas hier machen
key value und und ist value jetzt der body oder wie ist das ach tatsächlich ja gut das
ist schon mal gar nicht ok ok ich ja ja aufhören aufhören nicht so viel ausgeben frage funktioniert
zwei unter ubuntu gibt es da projekte dazu ja wüsste nicht warum das nicht funktioniert
muss halt wayland verwenden als display manager also also was will ich denn jetzt eigentlich
machen ich will jetzt haben ikon registry push und da jetzt quasi key value body das funktioniert
natürlich nett das wäre zu einfach unexpected token ach so wahrscheinlich muss ich das da
nenne ich es passt ob das jetzt funktioniert was ich mir da überlegt habe dass du geht
ok so und jetzt sagen wir hier filtert ikons nicht mehr objekte sondern ikon registry ich
mache den kram mit dem filter mal weg braucht kein mensch du kannst so machen a destruct
dings bums operator oder wie das heißt ja die construct operator oder wie heißt das
explode operator oder wie heißt dieses ding punkt punkt punkt das probiere ich gleich
mal spread operator gachibus ja genau stimmt so hieß das ikon registry moment ja ok so
objekte ist schon mal gut es ist jetzt steht da irgendwas drin ok ok nice nice ist gut ist
gut aha ikon sind schon mal da gut nice nice ok so ein popup so popup beim drüber gehen
wäre noch nice oder ja ich hatte schon ikons aber ich will mehr ikons ich will material
design plus alle anderen so ein popup wäre nice dass man sieht was es ist also was meintest
du will ich haben ikon registry gleich titel attribute war feifertheim macht es das dann
automatisch keck weh warum geht das nicht warum ist das jetzt rot
ok bringt das jetzt was an der stelle
ach du scheiße monka es alda da wäre ich ja nie drauf gekommen aber aber wie kriege
ich denn jetzt den vater zusätzlich noch rein wenn ich das weglasse geht's wenn ich
das hinzumache geht's nicht einfach nur titel element ne dann ist das sprocken
drüber ich meine das hier macht pass elemente fügt das hinzu das muss doch eigentlich gehen
das verstehe ich nicht
ja das war schön und gut
kann man diff tittle machen meck weh ach easy ja dann dann machen wir das so name äh
heißt es name ne das heißt key key da guck mal jetzt haben wir sogar noch oben drüber
wie der krempel heißt das ist ja pock pock pock g ist das so also was meintet ihr jetzt
muss ich machen so und damit könnte ich meinen ganzen meinen ganzen müll hier ne ha ha ha
funktioniert nicht anzeige ist raus
projekt machen thema darf man sich selbst aussuchen hast du irgendeine coole idee was
gut moment muss es in arduino sein oder muss es arduino kompatibel sein weil ein arduino
hat im einsatz her relativ beschränkt ansonsten ja in den display mit ansatz sowas gibt es
auch ich will aber ein raid raushaben
boah was zum javascript kram wieder das ist ein modul hier an der stelle oder was ist
das überhaupt was ist das wie lässt man sich den typ ausgeben moment gibt es sowas wie
type type auf type auf objekt
ist ja was so funktioniert es schleife einfach schleife drüber gutes loop ok gut so und
das gleiche also brauchen wir brauchen wir doch das was ich mir hier gedacht hab so und
jetzt rufen wir das auf für alle meine ikons jetzt und das funktioniert arrow guck mal
jetzt haben wir alles drin alle ikons jetzt haben wir hero ikons mdi ikons unicorn ikons
und fluid ikons einfach so ohne dass man großartig was machen muss und jetzt hört gar nicht
mehr auf so viele ikons man massive ikons wir haben jetzt moment wir zählen jetzt mal
log ikon registry mach noch tabs alter wie wie advanced soll es denn noch werden längs
wir haben 20.000 101 31 ikons nee man muss ja du hast recht tabs wäre natürlich jetzt
auf dem desktop eine coole funktion aber ganz im ernst wozu tabs der leht die dinger lazy
ist total da braucht man eigentlich nicht so suchen wir mal zum beispiel nach youtube
irgendwie ist es problem wow ach das ist wieder weil mein weil ich das weil das kaputt ist
die suche geht nicht warum geht die suche nicht ah weil ich die suche auskommentiert
hab ja das würde das würde erklären warum die suche nicht funktioniert ok ikon registry
filter ikon so und jetzt will ich nicht ikon filtern sondern ikon key ikon filter ok facebook
youtube gaming das verwendet den kram überhaupt irgendjemand so wir müssten jetzt noch eine
sache dabei speichern wie kriege ich jetzt überhaupt den name davon raus ich hab ja
nur die ikons ich weiß ja gar nicht was das für namens chat jetzt jetzt wirds richtig
eklig aber gibt es in javascript was was mit den variablen namen anzeigen lassen kann
davon nee wahrscheinlich nicht spätestens hier wäre es ja ikon set immer das gleiche
nee nee das war mal nicht so ich fürchte ich muss doch alles importieren ich fürchte
ich brauch doch sowas da und das weg warum darf das jetzt eigentlich nicht geklammert
sein und das andere darf geklammert sein muss man nicht verstehen ich brauch doch das so
weil jetzt hab ich den name dazu audio genau jetzt hab ich den name dazu und da sind dann
auch so sachen drin wie info info also da kann ich nämlich sowas hier sagen keine ahnung
info ikon set info name name so und dann braucht man ikons unten drunter das heißt wir wollen
jetzt ikons an der stelle dann funktioniert es wieder das ist immer noch nicht kaputt
wir machen die mdi ikons als erstes ja weil ich glaube mdi ikons sind am beliebtesten
so und dann sagen wir key path haben wir mal hier paar zeilenumbrüche rein ist besser
prefix nehmen wir wobei ich schreibe alles reinkommen prefix
ist er jetzt in info ach nee der prefix ist einfach so da so gut und das können wir dann
hier unten beim titel nicht key sondern key plus ikon prefix moment prefix heißt prefix
weil er vorne steht oder minus dazwischen ist egal ja guckt mal mdi jetzt haben wir
sogar noch dabei stehen jetzt kann ich es wahrscheinlich sogar auch durchsuchen hier
fällt nochmal youtube so das ist das youtube mdi ikon youtube gaming mdi mdi youtube studio
mdi youtube subscription mdi youtube wo ist der rest ah hier unicorn ikons youtube unicorn
ikons youtube ok twitter ja funktioniert das finde ich gut variablenamen als twing nee
nee nee damit sowas will ich jetzt gar nicht anfangen list digital verkacken also nicht
total eklig machen nice das gefällt mir guck mal und jetzt könnten wir theoretisch beliebig
viele ikons reinhauen es reicht glaube ich an ikons wir müssen sie jetzt ja nicht komplett
übertreiben rollo wl oder es ist rollo wl ist owl was mit overwatch league nee wahrscheinlich
nicht oder danke für den sub sechs monate da in den preis champ gibt es nicht mehr da
war mir das zu anstrengend die crawler zu updaten also arduino stimmt ja also was könnt
du machen lass mal was überlegen also es muss es muss ein arduino sein ja kein esp oder
nochmal so als frage also kein esp es muss ein echter arduino sein und welcher arduino
einer von den von den ganz oldschool dingern mit zehn megahertz oder acht oder so oder
einer von den neueren die vielleicht auch wlan haben ist das ist haben das da das dein
dein professor oder dein lehrer irgendwie spezifiziert ja das ist egal ja da kannst
du danke dann hast du dann hast du mehr möglichkeiten wobei ganz ehrlich was man nicht baut kann
auch nicht kaputt gehen ja aber nicht in dem kleinen bastelprojekt was eigentlich um den
so geht also ich ich würde ja ich würde irgendwas mit wlan machen aber da müsstest du ja zum
demonstrieren in wlan packen das ist blöd das ist blöd ja also was was glaube ich ganz
gut ankommt wenn du dir so ein oled display kaufst so ein kleines warte mal hier amazon
irgendwie so ein kleines oled display oder so holst und dann irgendein sensor oder kannst
du zum beispiel du kannst hier zum beispiel also was ganz einfaches was mir jetzt einfällt
hast du ein 3d drocker du kaufst dir den bme 280 das ist ein luftfeuchtigkeit temperatur
und luftdrucksensor und ich weiß ja immer die frage was das ganze für umfang haben
soll ja da liest du den sensor aus und lässt die werte anzeigen auf dem display aber nicht
einfach nur die werte anzeigen sondern du machst noch irgendein symbol dabei das anzeigt
ob das jetzt gut oder schlecht ist da suchst du dir im internet mal irgendwelche tabellen
also quasi luftfeuchtigkeit und temperatur gibt ja so tabellen wo man sagt hey das ist
quasi gutes klima das ist schlechtes raum klima da machst du einfach eine anzeige auf
dem display so nach dem motto gutes gutes raum klima neutrales raum klima und schlechtes
raum klima das kannst du das kannst du relativ easy machen du brauchst ein display und du
brauchst eine temperatur also nimm brauchst du übrigens den da brauchst du nicht by the
way das gibt es viel günstiger sind drei stück gibt es viel billiger auch bestellts
aber nicht aus china das dauert aktuell ach ja und wenn du es nicht wenn du nicht den
guten sensor willst du kannst immer noch temperature sensor d h t 22 oder so du kannst immer auch
die d h t 11 glaube ich das sind die ganz billigen das sind die ganz billigen also wenn
du wirklich also wenn du wenn du gar keine kohle ausgehen willst dann hol dir so was
hol den d h t 11 billig das ist auch ein luftfeuchtigkeit und temperatursensor oder ne oder war das
nur temperatur nee humidity ja ich mein es muss ja nicht wirklich genau sein oder es
geht ja zum demonstrieren dass du den kram programmieren kannst hol den d h t 11 der
ist nicht sonderlich genau der liegt auch manchmal 1 2 grad daneben sollte er eigentlich nicht
aber der ist nicht so genau da bist du mit 5 euro dabei hol dir ein d h t 11 und hol
dir irgendwie ein günstiges display sowas hier zum beispiel und dann mach irgendeine
anzeige oder sowas die dinger sind auch cool mit farbe du kannst auch du kannst auch display
gibt es auch günstige displays mit farbe sowas hier zum beispiel oder du nimmst du nimmst
sp32 gleich mit einem eingebauten farb display oder sowas aber ich würde ich würde ich
würde es einfach halten was hältst du von was hältst du von dem vorschlag du nimmst
ein luftfeuchtigkeit temperatursensor ein display und lässt anzeigen ob das raumklima
gut oder schlecht ist screamer und dankeschön für den zapp und wenn du 3d drück hast kannst
du gar noch ein case für ausdrucken also das ist easy das display und den temperatursensor
das musste im endeffekt nur anschließen und die library von github ziehen dafür sollte
als umfang eine kleine bachelorarbeit sein ich glaube das ist zu ja was denn jetzt soll
es nicht zu komplett sein oder soll es den umfang einer kleinen bachelorarbeit sein weil
das ist nicht schwierig ja sowas hier zu machen wenn es natürlich komplizierter sein soll
dann würde ich sagen dann ist das nix also naja temperatursensor und das display ansteuern
ich würde mal sagen 50 50 na gut es ist 100 150 zeilen 150 zeilen 200 zeilen sourcecode
oder so vielleicht 200 zeilen ja was denn nun soll es jetzt den umfang einer kleinen
bachelorarbeit haben oder soll das einfach nur zeigen dass man also wenn wenn du einfach
nur zeigen kannst dass du mit der sache umgehen kannst dann würde ich das dann würde ich
das wirklich machen dann würde ich das wirklich mal temperatursensor display und du rechnest
ein anhand der temperatur in der luftfeuchtigkeit aus ob das raumklima gut ist oder nicht man
kann das natürlich noch beliebig weiter aufbauen von wlan mqtt sonst was in der richtung aber
das ist eines der simpelsten sachen die du machen kannst oder du kaufst den fertig ins
bord mit display schon drinnen dann musst du dir nicht mehr mit extra display aussuchen
kriegt ihr das geschickt irgendwas gestellt ich habe keine ahnung was eine kleine bachelorarbeit
ist was das für einen umfang haben sollte ich habe keine ahnung kann ich dir nicht
sagen aber ich finde es eigentlich gar nicht schlecht so jetzt haben wir uns da mehr mehr
fällt mir dazu nicht ein weiter das einfügen der bilder geht nicht mehr die temperatur
binär ergibt es gibt sich tausende der warum funktioniert es jetzt das einfügen nicht
mehr weil ich select icon mache select icon gebe ich das icon aus und das icon ist was
ist das icon was ich da ausgebe das komplette ding ja gut das kann natürlich nicht funktionieren
da müssen wir mal ein index select icon in insert icon event event details details
eigentlich das heißt wir wollen eiken punkt path haben studio woher willst du wissen dass
es das nicht gibt lügt doch nicht natürlich gibt es das vielleicht doch recht ich bin
ja auch doof hier muss ich pass hinschreiben geht immer noch nicht moment jetzt ist wahrscheinlich
meine meine funktion hier im eimer moment moment sekunde get pass das ist das passiert
noch auf material design icons keckow alda was zum teufel soll keckow sein material design
icons weg damit kann er nicht funktionieren das brauche ich gar mehr das das das ist
useless das brauche ich mehr mehr passt er ist auch da schon drinnen passt auch alles
hier schön sql injection auf geht's so request in module ja ich importiere den kram hier
noch irgendwo ich weiß jetzt pack wo helfer helfer was ist was importiere ich hier ist
doch richtig get pass vom icon name alda wo was wie wo habe ich hier dinger gemacht wo
verwende ich das überhaupt monka hier was hat er denn für schmerzen was ist das für
eine muss jetzt einfach mal neu starten wo verwende ich den krempel wo kriege ich das
denn jetzt raus an welcher stelle ich da noch ein import drinne hab woher weiß ich jetzt
wo ich da noch ein import drinne hab hier wahrscheinlich bei icon irgendwo die fehlermeldung
ist ja auch mal richtig richtig hängen geblieben hier habe ich das noch drin was control control
schrift f ach du meinst feife da das da war ich jetzt ja auch gar nicht mehr das ist useless
af moment wie kriege ich denn das jetzt dahin ach so ja material design icons das brauche
ich doch noch weil ich hier noch ich kommentiere das mal wieder ein leute ich lasse das mal
drinne ja ja import ist ok ist ok ich lasse ich lasse es mal drinne form das muss ich
dann später aufräumen vom mdi gelädt ist jetzt wieder ok name aber es sollte es sollte
jetzt trotzdem es sollte jetzt trotzdem funktionieren das muss ich dann anders nennen das war für
das material design zeug gut und gehts fack warum warum warum was habe ich denn jetzt
kaputt gemacht mein index wo sind wir denn jetzt insert icon ok icon was was kommt denn
da raus und die feier da stimmt irgendwas nicht das nicht icon passo moment da stimmt
was netz da ist irgendwas broken was könnte was habe ich denn da jetzt verkehrt gemacht
ich bin jetzt grad etwas ratlos icon pass undy feind ok log wir loggen wir loggen wir
loggen wir ein bisschen was event total easy wahrscheinlich custom event details icon icon
pass das ist eigentlich richtig moment das ist eigentlich komplett richtig was ich da
mache hier ist garantiert irgendwas nicht richtig es kept das sieht doch gut aus das
ist dann ok das muss ich anders nennen den kram das ist gar nicht das ganze das ist mann
das ist ja total einfach so jetzt geht ja das ergibt jetzt so wie ich es jetzt gebaut
habe eigentlich keinen sinn mehr ja ich glaube ich sollte das besser so machen das muss ich
anders machen das weiß ich spätestens morgen selbst nicht mehr ok nice ok bilder funktionieren
wieder twitter so unicorn unicorn icon bild bm da haben wir es so wir haben mehr wir haben
mehr icons wieder wir haben jetzt 22.000 20.000 31 icons perfekt so muss es sein empfehlung
für ein smart home gadgets was keiner braucht aber nice ist ja die meisten sachen braucht
keiner und sind nice wenn du also brauchen brauchst du eh nicht viel die meisten sachen
sind nice swell und view es nimmt sich ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel ich meine für view gibt
es deutlich mehr fertige integration und packages und sonst was das kann man glaube ich nicht
leugnen aber insgesamt es nimmt also eigentlich nimmt sich das gar nicht so viel kann man
auch beides schön lernen so was haben wir als nächstes machen wir noch was kurz überlegen
machen wir noch irgendwas swell ist mehr javascript also vielleicht wenn du die options die view
2 options API nimmst die man ja immer noch nehmen kann in view view 3 aber ansonsten also
du hast du machst bei view vielleicht ein ticken mehr hier unten in irgendwelchen template
magic sachen weil du eben fertige fertige oder mehr fertige libraries und und sachen
verwendet aber insgesamt nimmt sich das ja eigentlich fast gar nichts also so was hier
so was hier wie du irgendwelche hilfs guidelines machst müsstest du trotzdem in javascript
programmieren auch in view da bleibt ja nicht viel anders übrig das ehrlich gesagt es nimmt
sich nicht viel ich glaube da und ich glaube wenn jemand view kann kann er relativ schnell
swell und wenn er swell kann er relativ schnell in view gehe ich jetzt einfach mal von aus
bei react mag das wieder ganz anders aussehen da hat er noch mal ein bisschen andere philosophie
von nachdem man schreibt html in javascript und so dinger und von angular fangen wir erst
gar nicht an wenn man irgendwelche also in angular hätte ich hier wahrscheinlich einen
eine icon icon insert controller factory observer pattern gebraucht dass das funktioniert
oh das ist ein bug index content es ist weder tragable noch content es ist weder tragable
noch content so und jetzt sollte sich das auch nicht mal dran ausrichten ne gut sollte
nämlich komplett im hintergrund sein und hardcoded ist ziemlich bescheuert an der stelle
ich sollte da nicht 39 mm reinschreiben sondern ich sollte reinschreiben label label breite
und label höhe weil wenn ich die label höhe switche dann stimmt jetzt auch die anzeige
36 39 ansonsten war das hardcoded vorher und jetzt stimmt es ja wieder übrigens wisst
ihr was das für ein akt war dass ich das hier in dem bis ich das hier in der mitte
ausgerichtet hatte es war gar nicht so einfach da musste man sich am ende selbst ausrechnen
wo die mittlere position ist kommt das auf github ja wenn es denn wenn es dann drucken
kann ich glaube das nächste mal machen wir dass es drucken kann weil das ist glaube
ich der einfachste teil daran der drucker geht und ich weiß wie man den drucker anschreit
hast du schon mal mit gist gearbeitet nee habe ich noch nie gemacht das ist weltkit
das ist weltkit aber ich mache gerade nicht serverseitiges damit das coole was weltkit
ist ja zum beispiel dann eher wenn du keine ahnung von deinem backend noch irgendwelche
sachen abrufen muss und das kannst du serverseitig schon rein rendern und sowas was natürlich
cool ist es verursacht dann kein traffic weil das innerhalb von einem server bleibt
habe ich noch nicht gemacht bisher hatte ich auch keinen großartigen anwendungszweck für
aber ich stelle es mir cool vor wenn man zum beispiel ja zum beispiel man hat eine seite
wo irgendwo eine tabelle ist mit vielen daten dass die seite direkt gerendert werden kann
und nicht noch irgendwelche ap requests nochmal hin und zurück müssen dass es quasi direkt
reingerendert wird das stelle ich mir tatsächlich ganz nice vor das werde ich dann ausprobieren
wenn ich es mal brauche ich muss unbedingt machen dass ich das schließt das nervt mich
wenn ich hier reinklicke auf die stage und das menü geht nicht zu das nervt das nervt
mich stage on on wheel maus daun ja if selected note gleich null warum geht es bei selected
note gleich null eigentlich nicht zu sollte das nicht zugehen if tab
eigentlich eigentlich sollte das zugehen warum
geht das nicht zu ah bind aha two way data binding
alles klar ja dann kein wunder dass es nicht funktioniert hat
park ist funktioniert immer noch nicht warum nicht
das sollte doch zugehen warum erscheint das jetzt nirgendwo was ist das
hier achso an der stelle
ach moment ich bin ja bescheuert ich habe macht es ich macht es ja an der komplett falschen
stelle das war heute schon zu lange zu langer progas
stelle alter ich mache das ja komplett an der falschen stelle wobei selected tab ich
kann einfach immer sagen selected tab gleich null fertig zack zack jawoll weg damit wenn
ich wenn ich da reinklicke soll das weg so gut kann man nämlich die ganzen krempel
hier rausschmeißen ok nice boah ich kann nicht mehr denken leute haben wir noch irgendwelche
videos oder so die man gucken könnte ich meine es ist ja auch sinnvoll oder dass es
nach dem einfügen zugeht warum sollte es oft bleiben hat der überhaupt keinen sinn
mit dem qr code by the way müssen wir uns noch irgendwas überlegen ich glaube wir brauchen
irgendein qr code einfüge menü also irgendwie sowas halt für irgendeine einfügelsache für
qr codes oder oder wir machen das hier drüber oder wir machen das hier drüber dass man
dann einfach den text editieren kann vom qr code da muss ich was überlegen aber leute
ich kann nicht mehr denken zu viel haben wir noch irgendwelche videos offen von heute morgen
da sind ne ne ne ne ganz bestimmt nicht bettel feels big größte probleme ist alter diese
überschriften immer immer wtf doch das spiel hat außerdem so viele probleme eins weniger
und mehr macht es auch nicht aus das haben wir uns heute morgen schon angeguckt mit react
in in hundert sekunden aber grau ist am start aber irgendwelche videos nein nein nein ich
gucke mir kein 30 minuten video an dass zu viel progas stellt nein sollst du nicht nein
auch nicht auch nicht nein nein nein ne gibt nichts zum angucken und was wir nicht machen
chat sag ich euch gleich irgendjemand letztens vorgeschlagen wir sollen uns den talk angucken
von innen ccc talk von 2014 für irgendwelche ich weiß gar nicht was es geht irgendjemand
meinte es ist super keine poggers talk den sollen wir uns angucken ach ja sms abfangen
sms klauen von leuten oder irgendwie sowas das das halte ich geistig jetzt eine stunde
nicht aus das ist zu viel smart home inspiration toiletten waschmaschinen jardinenstangen
und ein autositz im bett ja warum nicht warum nicht haum automation geht immer
zwitschbord zwitschbord ist poc leute übrigens ich muss euch was zeigen pass mal auf moment
leute paint ich muss ich muss euch ich muss euch was zeigen paint moment passt auf leute
es ist fast geschafft es ging heute noch mal runter es ist fast geschafft ich bin fast
wieder unter 100 angefangen habe ich bei 100 sieben und halb oder sowas bald bald mache
ich hier auch gatchi roll durch zimmer easy ich hoffe ja mal nächste woche unter 100 ok
ich muss das lauter machen menschentiere automation ausgabe 11 hereinspaziert so wir facken noch
gar nicht lange rum oder verschwenden zeit und nettigkeit auf gehts david hat mir geschickt
wie er seine waschmaschine smart gemacht hat ok smarte waschmaschine ist das easy ist das
easieste auf der welt einfach eine wlan steckdose und am besten am besten ist noch wenn du eine
wlan steckdose hast die so halbwegs das muss nicht genau sein aber die halbwegs den strom
messen kann beziehungsweise ich den strom den verbrauch messen kann und daraufhin kannst
du dann irgendwie was triggern kannst du dir beispielsweise eine push notification schicken
lassen wenn die wäsche fertig ist oder sowas und das schauen wir uns jetzt mal an moin wir
haben unsere waschmaschine auszurollen und um das problem etwas zu lösen ich bin sehr
auf die problemlösung gespannt ich vergesse nämlich andauernd meine wäsche es gibt es
gibt tausende lösungen dafür ich wollte mal ich wollte mal ein bisschen was ähm ausgefallen
das machen ich habe mir einen rüttelsensor gekauft wusste dass es rüttel rüttelsensoren
gibt ist vielleicht auch was für denjenigen der vorher arduino projekt bauen wollte automatisieren
eine waschmaschine es gibt amazon rüttel rüttelsensoren gachi bass sensoren ja rüttel sensor ist gar
nicht was man da suchen muss überhaupt und da könnte da habe ich überlegt ob ich nicht
messen könnte ob das aufhört sich zu bewegen aber mit mit dem stromverbrauch messen beziehungsweise
mit wenn es da drunter fällt das ist eigentlich besser in der maschine oder im trockener zum
beispiel jetzt gerade der david mich nicht gerade daran erinnert dann hätte ich nicht
dran gedacht direkt nach dieser aufnahme ja ganz bestimmt habe ich eine kleine automatisierung
gebaut die uns auf einem eink display alle fünf minuten penetriert wenn die waschmaschine
fertig aber noch nicht ausgeräumt ist der typ ist ja geil das ganze habe ich mit home assistant
umgesetzt mit drei kleinen automatisierungen die den jeweiligen status überwachen oder
vibrations sind nicht rüttelsensoren ja so wie ein aquarator sind so und eine große und
was ist eigentlich das sinn davon dass er gerade in der waschmaschine filmt es ist jetzt nicht so
als hätte es irgendwas damit zu tun als würde uns das irgendwas bringen warum hat er eigentlich in
der waschmaschine gefilmt ernsthafte frage hat hat keinerlei auswege und relevanz dafür eigentlich
dass er in der waschmaschine findet wie man eine fehler kennung bei einem was ist denn das
diese so wärmedings sensor erkennen kann keine ahnung das einzige was du machen kannst ist wenn
er zu oft triggert kannst du in den cool down einbauen oder so die automatisierung sind recht
einfach mit der ersten prüfe ich ob der waschvorgang gestartet ist das heißt habe ich stromverbrauch
der kurzzeitig über einen gewissen peak geht dann setze ich den status auf waschen fällt danach
der stromverbrauch wieder auf eine schwelle unter zehn watt für für über zwei minuten dann setze
ich den status auf fertig und ist die waschmaschine dann im status fertig sende ich die benachrichtigung
an dieses kleine display alle fünf minuten das uns daran erinnert dass wir die weite eigentlich
müsstest du heutzutage so was mit ei gestützter bilderkennung aus der cloud machen ob deine
waschmaschine fertig ist genau schiene ausräumen öffne ich dann die tür kann ich den status auf
ausgeräumt setzen das funktioniert so gut dass sogar meine frau das ganze akzeptiert und sich
beschwert wenn es mal nicht funktioniert wird mich freuen wenn ich damit den ein oder anderen
auch inspirieren konnte seine waschmaschine ja ich glaube das ist eines der mit abstand aber
wirklich ganz ganz weit vorne mit dabei top fünf automatisierung die jedem was bringen und die
diese probleme die jeder schon hatte und es gibt auch mindestens genauso viele verschiedene
möglichkeiten dieses problem mit der waschmaschine zu lösen das hast du auf jeden fall ich muss mir
mal überlegen wie ich das angehe wir haben ja eine lg waschmaschine die theoretisch im wifi ist und
theoretisch in der praktik ist ne würde ich nicht verwenden muss dann nur ein türfenster kontakt
daran bauen da warte ich vielleicht noch ein bisschen bis der ganz kleine ein bisschen größer
ist und ein türfenster kontakt kann man machen dann weiß man ob man die schon mal aufgemacht hat
oder nicht aber eigentlich wenn du sie aufmachst dann also wenn du weißt dass sie aus ist und
fertig ist und aufmachst dann machst du eigentlich auch die sachen raus oder hat jeder so seins
und ich brauche nicht unbedingt ein display muss mir dann was anderes überlegen wie ich uns ärgere
aber die produkte die david benutzt hat und auch die anderen heute in den automationen sofern ich
sie finde verlinke ich unten in der video beschreibung auf jeden fall schon mal eine sehr schöne
inspiration vor allem für mich dieses thema mal anzugehen danke david natürlich darf auch
heute der hinweis nicht fehlen sendet mir eure automationen für jede gezeigte einsendung bekommt
ihr 51 euro amazon gutschein was und heute kommen die erstmals nicht aus meiner tasche sondern aus
der des sponsors aber damit überrasche ich dich wenn du es am wenigsten erwartest oder nach der
übernächsten automation mal schauen zeug punkten zeigen gibt mir deine automationen ich label mich
daran ich ja ist ja gut ich schicke aber trotzdem nichts ein im wahrsten sinne des wortes dann geht
es weiter mit daniels smart home bad das war es für mich leute da bin ich mal gespannt jetzt da
bin ich gespannt mal gucken ob da auch so ein so einen leisen klo hat ich habe folgendes problem
ne das ganz normal ist direkt gegenüber von meinem fenster ja da kann man durchgucken naja
aber das könnte man auch anderweitig fixen ja habe ich mir folgendes überlegt er hat
einen sensor dran wenn er das klo aufklappt geht das ding zu das ist feifheit
das finde ich cool leider ist das mit der umsetzung nicht so einfach ja da musste
in den motor da oben dran machen und so dass es ziemlich ist gebastel aber das ist das ist cool
das ist man hat sie eben auch kurz oben in der ecke gesehen ich weiß ob es erkannt haben auf
die geht auf die schnelle warte mal ich zeige euch noch mal kurz oben der motor
wo ist das zeig doch noch mal oben wo hat das denn man hat es doch eben oben gesehen
da habe ich mir folgendes überlegt sobald man den klo ist direkt wo ist das denn man hat mit dem motor gesehen
ich habe folgendes problem mein klo ist direkt gegenüber von meinem fenster und da kann man
durchgucken da habe ich mir folgendes überlegt sobald man den klo deckel jetzt sieht man es jetzt
sieht man ja also hat irgendein stepper motor oder was auch immer irgendein motor oben irgendein
controller irgendein wahrscheinlich 12 volt netz teil oder so das ist halt das problem bei
solchen dingern das ist halt das sieht nicht nur so aus das ist halt ziemliches gebastelt was ich
persönlich nicht schlecht finde aber je nachdem wer noch bei euch im haushalt ist gibt es leute
die reagieren ja schon allergisch wenn die fritzbox einfach auf dem schrank steht und man die sieht
dann muss man sich vielleicht was überlegen also für mich wäre das kein problem für andere
vielleicht schon und wenn man den klo wieder zumacht und er war länger als einige sekunden
offen gehen sie wieder auf das wird folgendes das ist ja geil der duft sprayer ich meine man
könnte auch das fenster aufmachen aber wer macht denn sowas oder aber man hat ein klo mit absaugung
da bin ich auch echt froh drüber dass mein klo eine absaugung hat und eine spüle für
poppers und eine heizung das ist wirklich nice das ist wirklich 6 hat alter das ist wirklich
ich mein klar es ist ultra gebastelt aber das ist wirklich cool das ist wirklich cool gemacht
absaugung ja der hat der hat einen ventilator drin und zieht das aus dem klo aus also ich
brauche das nicht das fenster ding ich würde mal sagen dass es selbst gebastelt das sieht
nicht so aus wie was was es fertig zu kaufen gibt
das ist ein motor und dann irgendwie so eine wir heißen das so ein gummizahnrad ding was
dann hier aufgerollt wird das gibt es das gibt es glaube ich so nicht fertig
ein neigungs sensor diese wird durch diese wird durch diesen mechanismus hier oben ausgelesen da
wird auch gleichzeitig der motor angesteuert in dem duftspray schauen ob ich das irgendwie
aufbekommen das ist ein ganz normales dm duftspray und hier ist ein ist dieser kleine chip eingebaut
geil den habe ich eingebaut der eben den motor ansteuert ein motor im duftspray alter da hat
er aber glück gehabt dass er ein duftspray gefunden hat wo genug platz ist da so ein motor
anzukriegen überraschend wenn dm bluetooth duftspray sprayer verkaufen würde
und hier ist ein ganzer mechanismus mit einem motor alles 3d gedruckt der mir das
fenster auf das ist wirklich next level hier es ist fantastisch ich weiß gar nicht was ich
sagen soll also gerade das gibt es mit motor wirklich er gut da hat die steuerung wahrscheinlich
gebaut also der steuer das selbst an weil ansonsten geht es wahrscheinlich nur mit
irgendeiner komischen app oder so bei der gästetoilette oder so ist natürlich super
praktisch da egal ist wer da drauf war der duft ist hinterher sichergestellt musstest du in der
entwicklungsphase die durchschnittlichen sitzungszeiten protokollieren ob und wie viel
duftspray du brauchst ja ich weiß auch nicht was ich dazu sagen soll es ist ein traum einstige
kritik könnte vielleicht sein dass die kabelführung und generelles verkleiden die einzelnen komponenten
noch etwas wo ich mir gedanken machen würde ist kann man nicht einfach einbrechen durch das
fenster dadurch dass es nicht zu ist auch fähig ist und als ausbaustufe würde ich mir dann vielleicht
wünschen eine vollautomatische klo bürste die dann hinterher auch noch einmal durchwischt also ich
hatte das schon sehr gern klo bürste ist overrated man braucht einfach ein klo mit abweisender
beschichtung da muss man kaum sauber machen daniel und dann hat sebastian ein abos fca 3000 smart
gemacht ein was jetzt gemeinsam raus was ein abos fca 3000 ja ist das ein fca 3000 ich habe meinen
abos fca 3000 mit der zugehörigen färben den smart gemacht das sind fingerabdrucksensor so
ein fingerabdruck tür türgriff oder oder was ist das in dem ich ein brett ausgedreht
beziehungsweise gefräst habe und der der die feinbedingung reinpasst anschließend habe ich
auf eine plexiglas leiste zwei switch 5 hat die nun wird das ist das was ich auch schon öfters in
videos bei euch mal gesagt habe ich in videos in in streams gesagt habe die switch die switch
spottinger die eignen sich dafür wenn alles andere nicht mehr funktioniert wenn du einfach
manuell wirklich noch knöpfe drücken musst dafür sind die aber gut an bedienung bedienen
ich checke aber immer noch nicht was es ist
ach das ist die fernbedienung für die tür das ist eine fernbedienung für schloss ach so
ok smarte schlösser und gerade schlösser mit funk kommen wir eh nicht also ihr wisst ich
bin äußerst smart home und technik affin was so was angeht aber smart locks muss nicht sein
hey siri terrasse zu das ist schon ich meine schon irgendwie sehr feif hätt ich ja moment
terrasse zu wer macht die tür zu wenn die terrasse auf und zu mit der kurzbefehle
warum hast du zwei hotel keycards betreibt neben beruflich noch ein hotel oder hast du
die etwa beim auschecken vergessen
ne so aber so rf id karten gibt's ja für apple und nahe
das ist vermutlich irgendein besonders gesicherte funk denn bei infrarot könntest du ja irgendwie
ein infrarot irgendwas ding nutzen das auszulesen und das signal danach zu bilden mit dem broadlink
infrarot ding an zum beispiel aber dann könnten die nachbarn das auch ja deswegen das ist auch
mein gedanke gerade wenn es um so security relevante sache mit smart locks und so was
geht da bin ich auch kein großer fan vielleicht schon sind das so zu machen also weil ich
davon ausgehe dass abus da ein bisschen was intelligenteres benutzt als ein 0815 infrarot
signal und so hat es auf jeden fall ein bisschen was von der useless box aber so ist es eben
komplett mit homekit und shortcuts kompatibel ohne irgendwelche bastellösungen habe gesehen
von der physischen bastellösung deswegen dafür sind die switchbots richtig gut aber
ist ja auch schön was mit den händen zu machen und so ein kleines bastelprojekt mit einfließen
zu können während so einer bastelfase und auch sonst im leben ist der sponsor des heutigen
videos ideal es ist nicht direkt aber auch eine fantastische art um zeit zu sparen und
wurde mit dem buch einfach nicht einfach nur die kernaussage das nächste preisgeld geht auf
jeden fall eine kochinsel automation mit türkontakt schauen wir mal rein hallo andreas heute wollte ich
mal als uns eher stiller zuschauer eine meiner automationen mit euch teilen und zwar haben wir
ich finde das cool dass sie alle automationen sagen auch keiner mit automation oder so was um
die ecke gekommen ist ein lichtpanel von ikea über unserer kochinsel wie heißt das ding die
ikea dinger haben wir immer abgedrehte namen ikea flor wie gesagt links und unten scheinen aus dem
programm zu gehen oder überarbeitet zu werden sind jetzt letzte chance bei ikea und das ist zwar schon
smart steuerbar mit siri und ikea fermbedienungen aber ich darf das weißt du das jemand sagt ist
das war haben wir nämlich so einen magnetischen puck um unseren herd zu steuern der hat eine
halterung in der schublade 3d gedruckt mit einem ak türkontakt und sobald der puck drin liegt geht
das licht aus sobald man ihn raus nimmt geht das licht an das heißt zum kochen muss man nichts
anderes tun als den puck was wie heißt das ding ikea has hens hens hens fick ok das ist
in den schrank na nicht alles ist sich b herauszunehmen hat automatisch licht relativ simpel
weil die fenster kontakte einfach nur auf einen magneten warten und es muss ja sein der dabei
war ich habe am hof da auch so was nicht mit dem offiziellen markiert wir hatten im urlaub auch schon mal so eine kochplatte mit so einem puck in der
ferienwohnung ich weiß nicht ob ich absolut überzeugt von der idee aber wenn man ihn hat ist es natürlich
perfekt für so spielereien wissen was ganz ehrlich manchmal sind richtig echte knöpfe einfach das
beste und gerade am herd brauche ich die ganzen spirenz hier nicht ich drücke knop und das ding
geht da nicht oder knop das ding geht aus danke niko hat den smarten briefkasten 20 update zu einer
automation die er schon mal geschickt hat bei meinem smarten briefkasten dass ich nicht die
klassische benachrichtigung jedes mal das mit meinem briefkasten leider nicht richtig gebacken
weil mein briefkasten zu unförmig ist kriege wenn er geöffnet ist sondern ich speichere den
zustand das post im briefkasten ist und schick mir die benachrichtigung nur einmal und erst wenn
der briefkasten gelehrt wurde dann wird die benachrichtigung wiederholt und ich habe das
ganze noch mit so ein paar anderen sachen im haus verknüpft und geht halt über zwei taster und wie
das ganze abläuft zeige ich jetzt mal einmal quasi in so einem kleinen durchlauf klassisch
wenn der briefkasten geöffnet wird gibt es eine benachrichtigung aufs handy die akustischen
assistenten im haus sagen auch noch mal bescheid und ich kann auch in meiner smart home app sehen
ist ist noch post im briefkasten wenn man jetzt nach hause kommt weiß man nicht ob der briefkasten
schon gelehrt wurde das ist auch eine der der top dinger schlechthin jedem das problem hat kennt
wohl jeder das auch noch mal mit der tür verknüpft led stripe geht auf farbe und es gibt eine
akustische benachrichtigung wenn ich jetzt den briefkasten lehre ist dann zweiter taster und wenn
das kann ich bei mir leider nicht machen mein briefkasten ist nicht eckig genug dafür ist zu
haus der briefkasten ist jetzt wieder leer zwei taster in den briefkasten gebaut einer ist an der
oberen klappe der aktiviert die benachrichtigungen und ich würde interessieren wo er das dran hat
wie ist die stromversorgung und wo hat er das angeschlossen das wird mich interessieren aus dem
briefkasten ist dieser status gesetzt dann macht quasi der taster erst mal gar nichts mehr und dann
geht es halt das einzige worauf noch reagiert wird ist der taster in der tür wenn der geöffnet wird
dann weiß das haus ok jemand kommt nach hause oder hat er das irgendwie in die wohnung geführt
ich gebe die benachrichtigung aus und das ganze passiert auch so lange bis da muss er in den
controller drin sein es muss irgendwie stromversorgung gemacht werden die tür geöffnet
also in der tür vom briefkasten geöffnet wird wenn das der fall ist weiß man ok jemand hat den
briefkasten gelehrt dementsprechend wird dann auch der status zurückgesetzt und wenn man dann die
klappe oben wieder öffnen würde geht das ganze wieder von vorne los zu dem video von mir was du
in deiner ausgabe nummer 6 minuten 11 schon mal das hätte mich jetzt interessiert wie das
funktioniert ich habe das noch ein bisschen gepimpt und zwar ging es da ja darum dass meine
jalousien und meine wadezimmer fenster so ein bisschen auf die luftfeuchtigkeit nach dem duschen
achten über benachrichtigungen schicken die jalousien automatisch rauf und runter gehen ich
habe jetzt die benachrichtigung ein bisschen geupdatet und zwar ist es so dass die benachrichtigung die
ich über telegram umsetze jetzt mir direkt die luftfeuchtigkeit ansagt das heißt ich weiß dann
quasi macht sinn das fenster jetzt schon zuzumachen oder macht eventuell auch sinn dass das fenster
einfach noch ein bisschen länger auf bleibt und damit man das dann nicht wieder vergessen kann
kann ich quasi sagen dass ich noch mal eine neue benachrichtigung hätte hier sieht man jetzt mal
einmal die benachrichtigung über den briefkasten david hat eine alte türklingel na da habe ich ja
auch schon mal einen spaß mit gehabt auch ich sehe schon wieder ein switchbot das sieht wirklich
nach einer alten türklingel aus schauen wir mal rein das das sieht richtig aus wie das alte haus
mehr oder weniger smart machen die türklingel sieht ja wirklich aus wie aus dem letzten jahrtausend
ist es auch zu einsteins zeiten wurde das dann auch eingebaut was für ein ding das ist ja mal
richtig antik das ding oder dann klingeln diese plättchen und ich habe hier einfach ein schaum
vibrations sensor und das ist eine gute idee das ist eine gute idee gute idee er erkennt das
und man kriegt eine mitteilung und das ist aber eine gute idee finde ich finde ich weiß dass
da geht es darum letztendlich du musst kreativ sein du musst mal sowas kreativ sein ja du kannst
nicht immer nur die dinger quasi exakt für also wenn man nur die ganzen geräte für exakt das nimmt
was die hersteller schreiben wofür sie da sind dann dann kriegst du ja die hälfte nicht automatisiert
das ist cool dass das funktioniert mega ok smartwatch braucht kein mensch steampunk automation auch
die magnet klingel von vor ein paar ausgaben aktualisieren so dann hat mevkin den open
source smart curtain rot version 0 1 geschickt den schon war das erst mal das hatte er erst
mal noch ein selten sellout eingebaut ging aber schnell wie nutzt diesen clip für irgendwas
anderes aber war das ein zeitraffer ist ja wirklich verrückt schnell für so eine gabin
öffnung ist richtig so ein langsamer losgesaust langsam über die schiene juckelt da müssen wir
mal eben schauen ok mevkin hat hier noch eine anleitung und die 3d druckteile für dieses
projekt verlinkt das schmeiß ich auch unten in die video beschreibung dass sie richtig auf
aufgeflutscht eure gardinen auch schneller aufmachen wollte oder automatisch oder überhaupt so
fabian quer lüften mit rückfrage alexa iow broker ich will euch heute meine lüft automatisierung
zeigen sieht fast aus wie beim fabian im dach geschoss alexa nein ein kleiner spaß also sie
kann auf alles reagieren die mäßigen gags auf diesem kanal kommen von mir jetzt mal richtig das
ganze noch mal auf mit homatic ip homatic monka es alexa ja diesmal richtig auch mal hier sogar mit
so einem komischen hydraulischen ding oder was das ist heimgestellt gleichzeitig keine ahnung ob
das was hydraulisches ist man hier oben durchlaufen aber ist vor allem was mit ein bisschen kraft
wahrscheinlich sind die fenster auch schwer der ist normalerweise natürlich länger so jetzt
ist die stromversorgung hier wieder zumachen mit den homatic ip ja kontakt ja angetrieben
werden die dach wie hat er die stromversorgung gemacht chat wie hat er die stromversorgung
gemacht da ist ein kabel hat er hier hinter der verkleidung irgendetwas für die stromversorgung
dahinter gelegt oder war da vielleicht schon was
weil ansonsten sieht man kein kabel man sieht nur hier ein kabel ne batterien bestimmt nicht
über einen homatic aktor der der grund ist warum ich diese automatisierung gebaut habe
weil ich nicht jedes mal zum querlüften runter laufen möchte während der arbeit
herzstück des ganzen ist das generische script dass ich sowohl auf github posten werde und dazu
einen link in der beschreibung das generische ein bisschen extra um den timer zu stellen ihn
zu löschen ja genau und halt die dachfenster anzusteuern motorisierte dachfenster sind ja so
ein bisschen mein kryptonit vielleicht muss ich das hier auch mal nachrüsten ich finde das immer
sehr cool wenn ich das sehe und wie bei ihm jetzt hier über der galerie noch viel mehr weil man
da ja irgendwie nicht so vernünftig rankommt ja ich hatte das problem mit der stromversorgung an
den fenstern das zum querlüften einfach an das andere fenster zu hängen finde ich auch eine gute
idee mit dem timer zusammen ist eine runde sache vielen dank für diese idee schon wieder david ist
das der dritte heute oder sind das die gleichen davids moment ich habe offenbar einfach über
durchschnittlich viele davids als zuschauer sind drei verschiedene es geht heute um ein
hörspiel zum einschlafen im schlafzimmer smart speaker ich habe hier das ding was unsere kinder
liebevoll kugel nennen sicherlich mit hey kugel das ding auch aktivieren kann das ist ein smart
speaker der bei uns im schlafzimmer steht und ich habe mir gedacht meine frau hört abends gerne zum
einschlafen hörspiel dafür habe ich eine automation gebaut die einfach random also zufällig eins ein
hörspiel abspielt eins von drei fragezeichen ein random hörspiel ok also da ist nicht mit wir
machen kurz pause und hören am anderen tag weiter dann kriegst du was neues ich habe jetzt hier um
das zu zeigen einfach mal lizenzfreie musik hinterlegt das funktioniert ganz einfach wenn ich
diesen knopf hier drücke dann wird das wiedergegeben und wenn ich lange drücke dann wird das wieder
aufgehört das ganze noch mal machen das jetzt wirklich nicht sonderlich kompliziert und dann
habe ich noch in den anderen schalter das sofern die geräte die man verwenden in irgendeine art
und weise der ansteuerung ermöglichen ja und nicht super verrammelt nur mit offizieller china
chinesen cloud app sicherlich schöner lösen mit einem 5 button von ik oder sonst irgendwas aber
hier kann ich das ist gut das finde ich cool dass er das auch gleich noch eingebaut hat ich
meine man könnte alternativ eine x beliebige fernbedienung nehmen dann bräuchte man nicht
eine komische zwei knöpfe darum liegen haben eine billige fernbedienung im empfänger was auch immer
aber wozu weil wenn man die knöpfe hat und die ik er dimmer falls das ik er dimmer sind
wahrscheinlich oder die sind auch günstig kostet irgendwie 11 euro oder so das ein button
einstellt geht es dann irgendwann von alleine aus ist ja klar oder man kann lust mehr dann kann
das einfach ausmachen vielen dank damit wir das genau gebaut hat zeigt er auch noch in seinem
video wenn du dich da einfach inspirieren lassen willst du das genau so bei dir in
home assistant nachbauen dann findest du sein video auch unten in der video beschreibung und
dann habe ich noch die fortsetzung der schreibtischstuhl automation aus dem letzten video wie erinnern
schreibtischstuhl die schreibtischautomation wo der schreibtisch runterfährt sobald man sich
auf den stuhl setzt ich dachte das ist eine heizung und bobs zu wärmen das ist das ist
ein drucksensor wenn man sich drauf setzt flo hat offenbar aber aber aber warum also wenn er
aufsteht geht es dann wieder hoch oder wie also das geht quasi immer hoch und runter je nach dem
oder das wäre das das würde mich nerven das will ich nicht haben weil ich stehe oft mal auf
ich stehe oftmals auf gehe aufs klo ich stehe auf guck mal aus dem fenster wenn man irgendwo das fenster auf
ich gehe mal kurz runter in die küche und ich will doch nicht dass jedes mal der schreibtisch schon
runterfährt kfz zulieferer überfallen und jetzt sitzsensoren überall aber ihr kennt ihr das
sprichwort wenn man nur sitzsensoren hat dann sieht alles aus wie ein problem dass man mit
einem sitzsensor lösen kann oder so oder was er sagt guten abend hat so man posten was du für
ein stuhl hast ich habe ein senus mister 24 hier würde ich aber nicht kaufen weil er viel viel viel
zu teuer ist wenn man einfach mal ein stuhl hat um ein paar stunden drauf zu sitzen wenn du
allerdings also ich habe den stuhl hier wenn du allerdings täglich da acht zehn elf zwölf stunden
was auch immer drauf hockst dann finde ich lohnt sich das durchaus einen guten stuhl zu kaufen
muss ja nicht so ein mega teurer stuhl sein aber letztendlich klo und stuhl sind nicht zu
unterschätzen da kann man sich auch was gescheites kaufen und was ist wenn wenn sich die wenn sich
die leute wenn die sich bewegen im bett also geht geht dann licht an und aus oder der letzte muss
also nicht mal mehr sprichwörtlich das licht ausschalten das übernimmt das smart home also
ach nee das ist unterm sofa nicht unterm bett jetzt habe ich das gecheckt das smart home das
licht ausmachen ich muss noch in meine bettseite steigen und schon geht das hat er auch ein sensor
drunter jawohl schließt die tür ab und im rest der wohnung geht das licht aus ja smart locks
will ich vielen dank für die erneute einsendung und damit gibt es wieder einen gutschein ich hoffe
du kommst damit ja war doch ein paar coole sachen dabei ok leute
alter es gibt sachen die will ich gar nicht wissen
muss eigentlich wirklich alles mittlerweile life changing sein gibt es keine normalen
videos mehr das video kennen wir schon mit dem goldfisch
hau muss das alles life changing sein ich wenn man darf nicht vergessen die leute
hatten bestimmt die letzten was weiß ich 200 jahre wecker old school wecker
ja das mario video habe ich auch offen aber das ist mir zu viel progress kam nach progress
progress stream jetzt es ist bett getimed noch nicht ganz ich gucke jetzt noch
irgendwas aber ich mache den stream jetzt aus
ok leute dann machts mal gut
der titel ist clickbait ja wer hätte das denn denken können wie heißt die
serie die du heute morgen empfohlen hast homeland gibt's kostenlos bar prime
wir sehen uns leute macht's gut see you